RESPONSE TO THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES AS WE HAVE
BEEN DOING FOR THE PAST- CLOSE
TO TWO YEARS WE ARE LIMITING
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING SENATE
HEARING TO OUR SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING. RULES AND
WE'VE MADE ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES
TO HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE ARE
HOLDING THE COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE CAPITAL- WE HAVE
ONE. MEMBER ATTENDING REMOTELY
THAT A SENATOR GROVE WE ALSO
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AT OFFICE TO
APPROVE. DISSIPATING REMOTELY
AND I KNOW THE REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS KNOW THAT YOU MUTE
YOUR TELEPHONES OR COMPUTERS-
AND THEN YOU WHEN YOU'RE- WANT
TO SPEAK USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM- R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL ON YOU YOU YOU
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO UN MEET
YOURSELF WHEN YOU WANTED TO
START TALKING. AND PLEASE SAY
YOUR NAME AND- WHEN YOU WHEN I
RECOGNIZE YOU SO THEN YOU CAN
BEGIN. TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. HERE INTO THE HEARING
ROOM. AND WE ALSO ARE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE SO FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO GIVE US- THEIR
TESTIMONY BY TELECONFERENCE THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE THE ACCESS CODE IS
NINE FOUR ONE SEVEN FIVE ONE AND
YOU CAN FIND OUT ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE ALSO- WHEN WE
GET TO PUBLIC COMMENT THE
MODERATOR WILL PROMPT YOU TO
DIAL ONE THAN ZERO- AND- IT YOU.
THEN WAIT FOR THE OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER AND
THEN AT THE POINT THAT YOU'RE
WILL BE CALLED ON THE OPERATOR
WILL SALINE NUMBER. AND IN ORDER
FOR THE PUBLIC WHEN YOU'RE USING
THE TELECONFERENCE REST
UNDERSTAND YOU AND HEAR YOU
CLEARLY PLEASE MUTE YOUR DEVICE
THAT YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING THE
TESTIMONY. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING  HEARING
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
ARE. DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED-
LET ME SEE IF I HAVE A QUORUM
YET. I DO NOT SO WE ORGANISED AS
A SEPT. SO THAT WE DON'T DELAY
SINCE WE HAVE A HARD STOP AT AN
TWELVE NOON AS SOON AS WE HAVE
ENOUGH MEMBERS. HERE WHICH WE'RE
CLOSE TO I WILL HAVE MISTER
STEPPING TRUCKLOAD CALL THE ROLL
BUT IN THE MEANTIME WE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. ON
TODAY'S HEARING IS OUR- ON THE
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE THIS IS OUR
SECOND BUDGET HEARING. ON THE
PURPOSES I MENTIONED IS FOR US
TO HEAR FIVE BILLS THAT WE WILL
ACT TO ON TUESDAY. AND THEN.
THEY WILL BE SUBMITTED BEFORE
THE OUR RESPECTIVE HOUSES THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE ASSEMBLY NEXT
WEEK FOR THEIR VOTE. AND THESE
BILLS FOCUS ON OUR CONTINUED
RESPONSE TO COPE AT NINETEEN AND
THEY INCLUDE A RE AUTHORIZATION
OF SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE.
AND AN APPROPRIATION TO INCREASE
TESTING CAPACITY ENHANCE AND
EXPAND THE VACCINATION PROGRAMS
BOLSTER OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
SUPPORT FRONT LINE WORKERS AND
ADDRESS THE CURRENT SURGE IN
CODE NINETEEN CASES DUE TO THE
OMICRON PERIOD. WE ALSO ARE
GOING TO BE- ACTING ON A BILL
THAT WOULD LIFT THIS SUSPENSION
ON A COUPLE OF- TAX- ACTIONS
THAT WE SUSPENDED IN TWENTY
TWENTY AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC WHEN WE WERE EXPECTING
REVENUES TO DROP. AND SINCE WE
HAVE NOT EXPERIENCED THAT WE ARE
GOING TO LIFT THOSE THAT
PROPOSAL BEFORE US IS TO LIFT
THOSE SUSPENSIONS. WE ARE ALSO-
ACTING ON A BILL THAT WOULD HELP
US ENSURE THAT THE RELIEF AND
PROTECTIONS THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
TO BOTH TENANTS AND LANDLORDS
FROM THE FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WE
BOTH HAVE HAD IN ANTICIPATED
COMMON. IN WE HAVE A BILL THAT
WOULD ENABLE US TO ACCESS THOSE
QUICKLY. ON AS I MENTIONED WE
HAVE A HARD STOP AT TWELVE
THIRTY SO WHAT ARE GOING TO DO
IS HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PRESENT. ALL FIVE BILLS
. AT ONCE MEANING WERE IT IS
SOMETIMES WE PRESENT ONE AND
THEN HAVE DISCRETION IN PRESENT
SECOND THEN HAVE DISCUSSION BUT
INSTEAD TODAY WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THE PRESENTATION ON ALL
FIVE. THEN I WILL OPEN IT UP TO
YOUR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ON
ANY OR ONE OR MORE OF THOSE
BILLS AND THEN FOLLOWING BATCH I
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
AND THEN WE WILL. TAKE OUR
MOTIONS AND VOTES SO. LET ME SEE
. IF THE SUPERVISORS NOT HERE
RIGHT NOW SO INSTEAD WE ARE
GOING TO GO. TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE- TO START AND
THEN OF COURSE THE L. A. O. WILL
ALSO PRESENT. THE DAILY
OVERNIGHT OKAY SIR INSTEAD THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE WEALTH OF
COURSE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ALWAYS PRESENTS ARE BILLS- SO
LET ME SEE I STILL DON'T HAVE
QUORUM YEAH- SO WE'RE GOING TO
GET START AS THE SEPT- LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND OF COURSE WE'LL
START NEW ORDER OF THE BILLS
HOWEVER AS I SAID WE'LL DO ALL
THE BILLS THAT WENT SO THE FIRST
ONE IS AB ONE FORTY SEVEN THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR. AND- ERIC
LEAD FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN. YES
THINKING ABOUT CHAIR- GOOD
MORNING AT YOUR SKINNER AYE
STERN NIELSEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- COOLEY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HERE TO
PRESENT ON AND EARLY ACTION
BUDGET AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE- THIS PACKAGE
INCLUDES A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
ALONG WITH FOR A COMPETING
TRAILER BILLS AS A TRANSIENT-
THAT INCLUDE FUNDING AND OUR
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS IMMEDIATE
CONCERNS. IMPACTING CALIFORNIANS
THAT CANNOT WAIT FOR A JULY ONE
EFFECTIVE DATE. I WILL BEGIN
WITH A AT THE BY BILL JUNE AND
ON THE- HEATHER MILLS- AB ONE
FOR SEVEN A BUDGET BILL. THAT
AMEND THE TWENTY ONE BUT ACT THE
BILL INCLUDES SEVERAL
PROVISIONS- IT AND I'LL START
WITH THAT COULD BE COSTS BUDGET
BILL INCLUDES ADDITIONAL DIRECT
RESPONSE COST ABOVE THE ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. BUDGET ACT- BRINGING THE
TOTAL TO TWO POINT SIX FIVE
BILLION- OR ONE POINT NINE
BILLION ABOVE THAT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR- AND SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
TRANSFERS ONE POINT NINE BILLION
TO THREE STATE DEPARTMENTS- AT
THE FIRST IS THE APARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ONE POINT SIX
BILLION TO SUPPORT TESTING
VACCINATIONS MEDICAL SEARCH.
CONTACT TRACING- OPERATIONAL
SUPPORT. AS WELL AS BORDER
RESPONSE OPERATIONS. ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO THAT ARE OF
CORRECTION AND WE HAVE. FOR
STATEWIDE TESTING OF IN CAR.
INDIVIDUALS AS WELL AS STAFF.
AND A HUNDRED MILLION IT TO THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES FOR
ADDITIONAL PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND OTHER DURABLE
MEDICAL BUT- AT THESE FUNDS WILL
BE SUBJECT TO THE TRANSPARENCY
PROVISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN THE CONTROL SECTION.
ELEVEN POINT NINE ONE OF THE
CURRENT BUDGET ACT- AND THAT
REQUIRES A TEN DAY NOTIFICATION
TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. FOR ANY TRANSFERS
MADE. IN ADDITION- THE- OF THE
BILL PROVIDES A LOAN TO THE
STATE RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AND A LOAN OPTION FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. THAT ARE
OPERATING RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS THESE LOANS TO SERVE.
AS A BRIDGE AS WAS MENTIONED FOR
THE STATE AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO CONTINUE TO
DISTRIBUTE RENTAL ASSISTANCE. TO
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS IN
ANTICIPATION OF ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING BEING MADE
AVAILABLE FOR THIS PURPOSE. THE
BILL ALSO INCLUDES- OR ALLOCATES
THIRTY MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT INCREASED COSTS
PRIMARILY ASSOCIATED WITH.
COMPLETING THE ENGINEERING AND
INSTALLATION OF TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S NECESSARY TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS OR ENERGY GENERATORS
THAT WERE PROCURED DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ENERGY
EMERGENCY TO COMPLY WITH AIR
QUALITY PERMITS. THE BILL
PROVIDES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WITH AN EXEMPTION
FROM THE PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE SO
THAT THE DEPARTMENT CAN EXECUTE
NEW CONTRACTS WITH CURRENT
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT FUNDERS- WHEN THEIR
CONTRACTS EXPIRE. IN APRIL OF
THIS YEAR. THE LANGUAGE IN A
LEFT OFF AND BUT- THE BILL
INCLUDES ONE POINT SIX MILLION
CHEN FUND TO. THAT ABOUT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH INDUSTRY HUB
PROGRAM CONSISTENT ITH AB
FORTY. THE BILL EXAMS ANY WAS
THE FROM CAL- PAYMENT PROGRAM A
STAB IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT FOR THE PURPOSES OF
STATE INCOME TAXES- AS WELL AS
FOR DETERMINING ELIGIBILITY FOR
STATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. OFFER
CHILD CARE THE BILL SUPPORTS
FUNDING FOR COSTS RELATED TO
ADMINISTERING SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS PROVIDERS IN GENERAL
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS INCLUDED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. AND IT ALSO PROVIDES
TEMPORARY SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
TO LIFE CHILDCARE CENTER-
VOUCHERSFUNDING FOR RELATED TO
ADMIN. THOSE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS. FINALLY THE BILLING A
CHEF FROM FEDERAL ALL AMERICANS
FIND. A FUNDS THE GENERAL FUND
OTHER FINE TO MAX FUN- AND
STREAMLINE FEDERAL REPORT.
MOVING ON TO. THE OTHER TRAILER
BILL. I'M A EIGHT AM MIDNIGHT
CALLER TO IN RIGHT CANISTER CORE
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ON.
ERICA CAN MISTER SEVENTY WE CALL
ROLL SO I TO STOP QUORUM.
SENATOR SKI. I'M HERE SKINNER
HERE. NEW CABALLERO HERE
CABALLERO HERE CORTESE YOUR
PROTECT HERE DOLLY DOLLY HERE TO
ROB. TORONTO HERE EGGMAN HERE
EGGMAN HERE GROWTH. CENTER GROVE
NEWS PER DISSIPATING REMOTELY
ARE YOU- YOU CAN PROCEED.
KAMLAGER COME OVER HERE LEHRER
HERE THEY'RE HERE MCGUIRE. IN
THIS MELENDEZ HERE MAN NEWMAN
THE TROUBLE TOWBOAT HERE AN HERE
PAN HERE STERN BY CAL SKI MY
COFFEE HERE. NEWMAN HERE. THANK
YOU MISTER SEVEN SHOT THAT- DOES
ESTABLISH QUORUM SO WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE PRESENTING THE BILL'S
AS I INDICATED IN OUR OPENING GO
AHEAD- MISLI. THANK YOU. ON THE
FIRST TRAILER BILL IS EIGHTY
EIGHTY FOUR- IT'S THE KOBE
NINETEEN SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK
LEAVE TRAILER BILL- IT'S A FIRST
EARLY ACTION TRAILER BILL AND IT
DEALS WITH THE IMPRINT. OF
PICKED- IT'S AND- EARLY ACTION
BY. THAT CALIFORNIA'S TAKE
ACTION NOW PLUS THE SPREAD OF
COMMUNISM- AFFECTS WERE THERE.
HOPE CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITIES
AT LARGE I'M TO LIMIT
TRANSMISSION WORKERS WILL BE
ABLE TO TAKE A TIME OFF AS
NEEDED APPOINT OTHERS SICK WELL
THAT WAS AN INCOME- THIS BILL
OVER. AND TO PROVIDE UP EIGHTY
OUR OF NINETY SUPPLEMENT PAY FOR
LEAVE TO ALL OF THROUGH THE END
OF SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR. IT
DOES EXAMS- INDEPENDENT. AND
EMPLOYERS WITH TWENTY FIVE OR
FEWER EMPLOYEES- IMPORTANTLY
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THE-
AWESOME ONE OF PAID SICK LEAVE
WILL COVER OVER 75% OF ALL
EMPLOYEES. OF THE STATE. ALLEN
EMPLOYEES WE USE FORTY HOUR OF
COVER. SACRAMENTO PEACEABLY BY
CERTAIN. INCLUDING IF THEY IF
THEY MEMBER UNDER A QUARANTINE
OR ISOLATION ORDER- AT PUBLIC
HEALTH. ADVISED A HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER. I OUR WORK FOR. DUE TO
COVER NINETY CONCERN. ARE EXTRA
. COULD NOT SOMETIME AND SEEK A
MEDICAL. ATTENDING AND A PLATE
FOR COULD BE. BACK OR BOOSTER.
EXPERIENCE SYMPTOMS RELATED KOBE
NINETEEN. OR CHARACTER CHILD TO
SCHOOL OR- CARE. AS CLOSE AS OF
COOKING NINETEEN THE PROGRESS. I
AM EMPLOYEE MAY I. UP AND IT
DOES FORTY HOURS- FOR A TOTAL
OUR- IF THE COVERED EMPLOYEE THE
FAMILY. TODD POTS. FOR KOBE.
NINETEEN ON THE BILL DOES NOT
WORK EMPLOYEES TO A MERGING
TEMPORARY STANDARD SLEEP YOU.
THE SUB PAID US LEAVE. THE BILL
FROM COMPANY SUPPLEMENTAL PAY
SICK LEAVE IT SO- OF SIR. ARE I
HFS WORKER AT WEBER PERSONAL
CARE. PROVIDERS FINALLY THE
PROVISION OF THE BILL ARE ACT TO
SEE LEAVE TAKEN BEGINNING JAN
FIRST UP. TWENTY TWO. AND MOVING
ON TO THE TRY BILL. WHICH IS. AT
CELL- THE SMALL BUSINESS REVENUE
TAX TRAILER BILL. THE
CREDIBILITY FOODS MANY SUPPORTS
FOR BUSINESSES- A CHURCH. THE
BEGINNING THE- HEARING INCLUDING
THE MILLION OF SMALL THAT WERE
NOT IMPACTED BY THE COBIT
NINETEEN. IF SUPPORTERS EVER
APPEAR OF THE LIVE DEMOCRAT AND
THAT LAW OR AND ALLOW YOU SEE
FOR THE TWENTY TO TAX YEAR- FOR
BACKGROUND THE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
I'LL INTEREST TO A SIGNAL-
EXPECTED STRUCTURAL AT ACCIDENT
AGAIN DROPPED REVENUES. ENACTED
REVENUES THAT INCLUDE IT TOUGH
FOR SUSPEND ON L. THE USE OF AN
ALL OUT- AND LIMIT THE USE OF
THE SUBSTANCE TAX CREDITS
TRAILER BILL REPEAL AND ALLOW I.
TAX YOU SEE LIMIT. ONE YEAR
EARLIER THAN WHAT EXPECTED. IT
WILL ALSO INCLUDE CONFORM TO TAX
TREATMENT OF BREAST READ BY.
PLAN AND SHUTTERS AND OPERATOR.
AND WHAT THE MEANS IS ANY L. A.
RESTAURANT. SHOP- MENU THAT RISK
A FEDERAL RELIEF FRIENDS ME DR
EXPIRE FOR THE EXPENSE RELATED
TO THE CRASH. FOR THE PURPOSES
OF STATE. ON THE BILL ALSO
EXPANDS ELECTED PASTOR AND ANY
TAX WHICH WAS INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT AND
ALLOWS CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
REDUCE. THEIR FEDERAL TAX BURDEN
WITHOUT REDUCING REVENUES FOR
THE STATE. FINALLY THIS TRAILER
BILL MAKES CERTAIN. THE BENEFITS
RECEIVED BY UTILITY CUSTOMERS
UNDER BOTH THE CALIFORNIA WATER
AND WASTEWATER ARREARS PAYMENT
PROGRAM AND CALIFORNIA. IT
PROGRAM- INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET I JUST- TO
SUPPORT A BUSINESS WILL BE NOT
FOR CALIFORNIA. AN R. X. FOR OF
DETERMINING ELIGIBILITY FOR
STATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. I'M
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT AB ONE
THIRTY NINE THE HUMAN SERVICES
TRAVEL THIS BILL INCLUDES A
PREPARATION FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS NECESSARY TO DISTRIBUTE
SOME ON A PAYMENTS TO FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS INCLUDED IN
THAT. BUDGET ACT IT ALSO MAKES
AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW FOR
INCREASED FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND ALLOCATING FEDERAL REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT FUNDING- RELATION
ACT ARRIVALS. AND LASTLY IT.
INCLUDES CLEAN TECHNICAL CLEAN
UP REGARDING SHELTERING OUT
ISSUE- FOR EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY
TWO HUMAN SERVICES ON THE. BEST
WE DIDN'T BERKELEY CHAPTER
LANGUAGES IN SB THREE FIFTY FOR
ALL. JUDICIAL OF INTO FAMILY. AT
AT LAST WE HAVE A AB ONE TWO
WHICH IS THE MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING AT THAT I HELLO
STRIVEN ALL. THIS BILL RATIFIED
AGREEMENTS WERE ENTERED BY THE
STATE BUT SEVERAL FAR UNITS AND
TO MONTHLY STATE. OF THE STATE
PROGRAM PART OF THE OVERALL I TO
BE. EFFICIENCIES FOR APARTMENTS
IN EMPLOYEES AND THE RIVER WE
FIND OR NOW IN- AT A RESULT THE
COVERAGE ADAM- THE BARGAINING
UNITS IN. A THIS BILL ARE- CASE
ATTORNEY AND LOG AND HEARING OF
CALIFORNIA'S LOCK SAID. ARE
PROFESSIONALS PROFESSIONAL SANTA
HAVE TO MAINTENANCE ENGINEER AT
STATION ENGINEER ARE DEVELOPER
TRYING SEVEN NINE I'M GOING FOR
THESE. AND THAT IS THE END OF
PRESENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MAY FOR. THE PRESENT ON THE FIVE
BE US- BEFORE ASK THERE ARE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES AND WANTED JUST
INDICATE THAT I ANNOUNCED AT THE
OPENING THAT A SENATOR GROUP
WOULD BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
AND SHE WILL. NOT BE FROM THIS
POINT ON SO SOON GIVE THAT NOTE
AND LET ME SEE WHAT AT LET ME
SEE FIRST IF MY VICE CHAIR
SENATOR NIELSEN WANTED TO MAKE
ANY- EITHER OPENING COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS AROUND ANY OF THESE
BILLS. RIGHT NOT YET AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT SO LET ME AS CALL
ON SENATOR CORTESE FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR PANFILO BY SENATOR TO
ROSTER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THE DISCIPLINE QUESTION ON- AB
ONE FORTY SEVEN SB ONE FIFTEEN.
AS TO THE TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION TO DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS- RELATIVE THE CODE
NINETEEN. I'D SAY A FEW OF US
HERE IN THE IN THE ROOM ON THIS
COMMITTEE WERE ALSO- PART OF
BUDGET SUB FIVE IN ORCHARDS
HERE- BUT THE EARLIER THIS WEEK
WE WERE PRESENTED WITH. ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT- DOLLAR AMOUNT I'M
TRYING TO LOOK THAT UP AS I-
WHICH WOULD A JUMPS OUT IT HAD
ME AS AS POSSIBLY RE DUNDON-
YEAH I JUST WANTED S. MISLEAD IF
. GIVEN THAT THIS IS- EARLY
ACTION IF THAT'S GONNA SOMEHOW
MITIGATE OR REDUCE OF WHAT WE
SAW IN IN SOME FIVE HOURS THAT.
SOMEHOW GOING TO BE TACKED
TOGETHER FOR A COMBINED LARGER
AMOUNT. I'M SURE THINKING
SATURDAY- SO THE- AMOUNT FOR YOU
IT'S FOR THE CURRENT YEAR THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL REQUEST IN THE
BUDGET FOR THE BUDGET YEAR WHICH
ARE ON TOP OF THIS ONE POINT
NINE BILLION SO THERE ARE
ROUGHLY ABOUT- I HAVE TO ADD
THIS TOGETHER BUT- THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR CONTACT
TRACING. AS WELL AS HOSPITAL AND
MEDICAL RESEARCH- WHY TESTING
AND ACTING DISTRIBUTION THAT ARE
CONTEMPLATED FOR THE BUDGET YEAR
SO IT WOULD BE ON TOP OF THAT.
THANK YOU. SO ESSENTIALLY IT IS
A COMBINED AMOUNT THAT SPREAD
OUT OVER- MULTIPLE BUDGET YEARS
IS WHAT I'M HEARING YOU SAY IF
THAT'S- RESULT OF A
MISCALCULATION. IT. FIVE IN
MISLEADING FACTUALLY JUST TO
CLARIFY HAJJAJ SAID USING IT
WITH IT IN A- YES CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CARE. GO AHEAD OKAY
GREAT I'M JUST TO CLARIFY FOR A
SENATOR COULD YOU SEE THE TWO
HUNDRED SIX. MILLION IS
ADDITIONAL FOR THE CURRENT YEAR.
SO THEY WERE ALREADY FUNDS
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET AX BORDER- THE
DEPARTMENT FOR COOK FOR
CORRECTIONS- IN ADDITION TO
THAT. WE FIND OURSELVES NEEDING
AN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED SIX
MILLION IN THE CURRENT YEAR. AND
THERE WILL BE AN ADDITIONAL
AMOUNT PROPOSED FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR. RIGHT IN IF I COULD JUST
FOLLOW UP. WITH ONE MORE
QUESTION MANAGER SO I MEAN I
KNEW THE BILL'S THEMSELVES-
DON'T TYPICALLY DEAL WITH ANY
KIND OF A DEEP DIVE ON
IMPLEMENTATION ACCOUNTABILITY
HAS JUST- BECAUSE OUR-
LEGISLATION. THAT SAID. IT IS I
KNOW THIS IS COME UP AND SOME
OTHER- PERHAPS A PREVIOUS- A
BUDGET COMMITTEE. HEARING OR OR
ELSEWHERE. THINGS MOVED-
NECESSARILY THE MOVIE SO QUICKLY
ESPECIALLY AROUND NINETY IT JUST
IT RAISES THE ISSUE FOR ME AND I
THINK SOME OTHERS SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES AS TO- HOW WE KEEP UP
WITH ACCOUNTABILITY. AND NOT TO
THE OVERLY PECAN DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS FOR EXAMPLE BUT AS
WE'RE ADDING. TWO HUNDRED AND
FIVE POINT FIVE IS YOU JUST
EXPLAIN FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR AND
WE'RE- TRYING TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS DECISIONS- IN
COMMITTEE ON THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR. HOW DO WE KNOW HOW THE-
HOW WELL THEY'VE DEPLOYED. OR
HOW EFFECTIVELY- YEAR TO DATE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN. IMPLEMENTED YOU
KNOW JUST FROM ACCOUNTABILITY
STANDPOINT AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT QUESTION IS FOR. MISLI YORK
OR SOMEBODY ELSE CAN. JUST GIVE
ME A TOP LINE KIND OF RESPONSE
TO THAT IN A WORD TO SENATOR
SKINNER JUST TO LET YOU KNOW
HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME HEARING
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER RIGHT NOW
. I'M SORRY SAY AGAIN- MISLI.
BUT YOU CAN'T HEAR US. IS THAT
THE ISSUE. OKAY YOU'RE HAVING
TROUBLE HEARING US ALL RIGHT
LET'S SEE- POLICY CENTER CORTESE
WE WILL GET YOU THAT ANSWER
LET'S JUST SEE WHAT OUR I. T.
PROBLEM IS AT THE MOMENT. I'M SO
COLLEAGUES I'M GONNA HOLD OFF
YELLING OR HAVING A HARD TIME
LIKE THIS IT DEPART THE I. T.
PROMISE OKAY. WELL NINE.
WHAT'S
NEW.
WHILE WE CORRECT THE I. T.
PROBLEM WILL BE ON RECESSED FOR
JUST FIVE MINUTES SO WHY DO WE
EXPECT TO HAVE IT CORRECTED
WITHIN FIVE MINUTES BUT WE ARE
GONNA PAUSE RECESSED FOR FIVE
MINUTES IN ORDER TO GET THE I.
T. ISSUE CORRECTED.
WE WILL NOW
RESUME THE HEARING SENATOR
CORTESE HAD THE FLOOR HE WAS
ASKING QUESTIONS OF OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- CENTER
CORTESE DO YOU WANNA YEAH I
DON'T KNOW IF. YOU WATER IT
WATER YOU JUST RESUME YOUR
QUESTION AND THEN WE CAN TURN IT
BACK TO ERICA GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IN AND I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY- IN THE END
DURING THE FIVE MINUTE RECESS-
IN IN. REVIEWING THE- MISLEADS
RESPONSE I UNDERSTAND THE ANSWER
TO THE QUESTION IN TERMS OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. WHAT'S BEING
ADDED TO THIS CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR VERSUS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT- IN SUBPART BUDGET COMMITTEE
RELATIVE TO THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
SO- I DO UNDERSTAND I DO HAVE
ONE ADDITIONAL. FOLLOW UP.
QUESTION IN- IF I'M A MAN
CHARGES YOU MAY BE LIKE A CAR.
BUT IT IS A QUESTION- ALSO IN
ALSO IN SUB FIVE WE SAW IT. THE
VACCINATION. FIGURES THE
PENETRATION OF THE VACCINATION
AMONGST BOTH EMPLOYEES AND
INMATES OF THE FEDERAL COURTS.
TO LET YOU KNOW YOU'RE BREAKING
UP AGAIN. FIVE FIFTY WONDER IF
IT'S YOUR IF IT SENATOR
CORTESE'S MIKE OR NOT. YOU CAN
HEAR ME- MS LEE CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES I CAN HEAR YOU OKAY SO GO
OVER. BYE WE'RE WE'RE JUST GONNA
MOVE YEAH GO AHEAD TRY HAT. AND
THEN TRY TO TALK LOUDLY OKAY I
WILL GO AHEAD WITH THE MASK THAT
NUMBER HAD- MISLI THANK YOU TO
FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS- AGAIN.
CITING THE WORK WE'VE BEEN DOING
IN IN THE SUB FIVE COMMITTEE-
AROUND CDCR- THE DATA THAT WE'VE
BEEN PROVIDED IN TERMS OF THE
PENETRATION OF VACCINATION- IS
CERTAINLY FAR BELOW 1100% IS A
IS A RECALL. EMPLOYEES WERE
HOVERING AROUND. THE 70% RANGE
INMATES WERE A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER. BACK TO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY QUESTION I WAS
ASKING EARLIER- IN AN INTERVIEW
FOR THAT QUESTION BUT THE
QUESTION WAS WAS. REALLY AREN'T
AT PERFECT AT WHAT POINT. ASIDE
FROM THIS. PROTECT YOUR BILL- DO
WE GET IT TO TAKE A LOOK AT.
THAT FOR THE INVEST ALREADY MADE
IN THOSE POLICIES ALREADY
ADOPTED SO THE QUESTION IS THIS
- MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WE
HAVE A 1100% VACCINE MANDATE
ESSENTIALLY- FOR CDC ARE. IF
THAT. BUT THAT MANDATE- WERE
ANYWHERE NEAR A 100% WOULDN'T
MITIGATE- THE NEED TO MAKE THESE
CURRENT INVESTMENTS THIS
INVESTMENT IN THE INVESTMENT
PRODUCT THAT WE WERE REFERRING
TO RELATIVE TO NEXT YEAR AND
DOES ANYBODY. HAVE ANY METRICS
ON THAT AS TO. HOW MUCH WE COULD
REDUCE BUT IN OUR OUR OUR
BUDGETARY COST HERE- BY SIMPLY
ENFORCING HUNDREDS OF VACCINE
MANDATE AT CDC ARE. BUT YES I
THANK YOU FOR REPEATING A
QUESTION I DIDN'T HEAR THE FIRST
TIME AND I JUST WANT TO- I LIKE
THE FACT THAT CDCR LIKE OTHER
STATE ENTITIES- IS REQUIRED TO
EITHER BE VACCINATED OR EXCUSE
ME DA INDIVIDUALS MUST SUBMIT
THEMSELVES TO TESTING SO IT'S
NOT A 100% VACCINATION MANDATE-
THE CITIES ARE LIKE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS- MUST. EITHER HAVE
TO PROVIDE PROOF OF VACCINATION
OR SUBMIT TO- A REGULAR TESTING
SO JUST TO CLARIFY THAT POINT-
AND YES IT THE NUMBERS ARE JUST
HOVERING ABOVE 70% FOR CCC OUR
STAFF JUST ABOVE 80% FOR I'M
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS- BUT
YEAH WE CONTINUE TO AS AN
ADMINISTRATION ENCOURAGE MORE
VACCINATION AND IN LIEU OF THAT
WEEK. WE REQUIRE THE TESTING.
WHAT WOULD WELL IF I JUST ASK-
BASED ON YOUR YOUR EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE WHAT WOULD BE THE
BEST WAY FOR US TO CONTINUALLY
MONITOR- THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN. TESTING AND VACCINATION
THE NEED FOR THESE INVESTMENTS
ON ON ONGOING BASIS- YEAH I.
SORRY I'M GETTING FEEDBACK NOW
THE CHAMBER- I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT THAT DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES DOES- COLLECT THAT
INFORMATION AND NOT JUST FOR CDC
ARE BUT FOR ALL DEPARTMENTS AND
CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND
ENCOURAGE- MORE COMPLIANCE IN
REGARDS BUT BACKING AND
PROTESTING- BEAT THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS THAT WE ARE REQUESTING FOR
THE CURRENT YEAR ARE LARGELY IN
PART DUE TO THE ARCHON.
ADDITIONALLY DALTON I'M A CRIME
VARIANT AND- BEING ABLE TO PIVOT
QUICKLY TO ADDRESS THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS ACROSS THE STATE
NOT JUST. IN- IN IN OUR PRISONS
. THANK YOU WILL WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE HR FROM MY AT
THE YOU FOR. MANAGE THANK M.
SENATOR COURT CASE- WE HAVE.
CENTER PAN FULLER BY CENTER
DRAWS FOLLOWED BY SENATOR.
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR. NIELSEN
AGHOLOR- SENATOR PM RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR VERY MUCH AND. WE
APPRECIATE PRESENTATION DIRECTOR
LEE- APPRECIATE THE- WHAT WOULD
IN TERMS- PROVIDING- THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE
WHICH IS ACTUALLY VERY IMPORTANT
PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURE MEANWHILE
I'M SURE PEOPLE. AREN'T COMING
TO WORK SICK- BRINGING CODED
INTO THE WORKPLACE- POTENTIALLY
EXPOSING CUSTOMERS OR OTHER
PEOPLE AS WELL SO REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT WERE RESTORING
THAT- BUT I DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE
IT DID HAVE A FEW ABOUT BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR SO FIRST OF ALL- AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR THE PROPANE
ONE POINT SIX BILLION TO JUMP ON
TO THE PART PUBLIC HEALTH. THE
THERE'S ABOUT WELL ALMOST FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION THREE HUNDRED
NINE NINE POINT ONE MILLION FOR
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
ADMINISTRATION- I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW WHERE THINGS WERE TRYING TO
DO IS WE'RE TRYING TO INCREASE
OUR RATE OF- VACCINATIONS
INCLUDING PARTICULARLY AMONG
YOUNGER PEOPLE WHICH AND FORTY
RIGHT NOW IS REALLY LOW I MEAN
WE'RE TALKING LIKE YOU KNOW
TWENTY SOME PERCENT 23% AT BEST-
ARE IN TERMS OF THOSE FUNDS- A
PORTION OF THOSE ARE. ACTUALLY
GONNA BE. TOWARD ACTUALLY
INCREASING ACCESS TO VACCINES TO
THROUGH. I'M A CARE OFFICES
PHYSICIANS OFFICES AND SO FORTH-
I THINK YOU KNOW THE
PEDIATRICIAN- SOMETHING I CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT- THERE ARE MAYBE
FAMILIES WHO AREN'T SURE WHETHER
ABOUT THE VACCINE. AND THEY WILL
ASK SOME QUESTIONS BEFORE THEY
GET THE CHILD VACCINATED THAT'S
WHAT THEY'D PREFER TO GO TO THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE BECAUSE THAT A
AFTER ALL WHERE THEIR CHILDREN
GOT ALL THEIR OTHER VACCINES. SO
WHEN IT COMES TO VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION MINISTRATION WHAT
PORTION OF THAT. COUNTRY THREE
HUNDRED NINE NINE MILLION IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO INCREASE-
AVAILABILITY VACCINATIONS
THROUGH- ESSENTIALLY PRIMARY
CARE SITES- PARTICULARLY YOU
KNOW DOCTOR'S OFFICE OF THE
PRIMARY CARE OFFICES. YES
SENATOR PAT I DON'T HAVE THAT
RESPONSE BUT I WILL SEE IF
ANYBODY ON THE LINE PERHAPS AND
DORSEY HAS SOME INFORMATION IN
REGARDS TO HOW MUCH OF THAT FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION. FOR
VACCINATIONS WOULD BE DIRECTED
TOWARDS PRIMARY CARE OFFICES.
GOOD MORNING MRS THAT CATHARINE
CLARK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WE WOULD HAVE TO GET
BACK TO THE SPECIFIC AMOUNT-
FUNDING GOING TOWARDS HER BACK
FOR THE NATION'S BY THE PRIMARY
CARE- LOCATION HOWEVER I CAN
TELL YOU THAT- BE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRAFTED. THE TOTAL MONEY
MOBILE FOR VACCINATION- IN THE
CURRENT YEAR THE TOTAL REQUEST
IS ACTUALLY- AROUND OF THE TOTAL
LEVEL IS FIVE HUNDRED AND- FORTY
EIGHT. MILLION MUSICIANS AMOUNT
REQUESTED IS THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY NINE MILLION. AND I'VE
THE TOTAL FOR THE CURRENT YEAR
AT THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
MILLION IS ALLOCATED FOR- OUT
REACH AND SUPPORT. AND ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN MILLION
MORE VACCINATIONS BY AND- MOBILE
BACK INSIDE. CERTAINLY WE CAN.
GET BACK TO WITH THE- SOME
AMOUNTS GOING TOWARD CARE
LOCATION. OKAY THAT THAT WOULD
BE HELP- BECAUSE SAID YOU KNOW
WHAT SIR AGAIN WE'VE OVER SITE
WITHIN THE OF DIFFERENT BUT
WE'RE A WALL ON BACKS AND RATES
AND SOME OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH.
THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW. PEOPLE
HAVE QUESTIONS THEY ACTUALLY
WANT TO GO TO SOMEONE THEY
ALREADY KNOW ORDER USED TO
GETTING THE VACCINES AND THAT.
TOO BECAUSE CHILDREN. AND IF
WE'RE NOT DELIVERING THEM AND
THOSE SITES- WERE MISSING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED BECAUSE THEY- MAY NOT
WANT TO GO TO A PLACE WHERE WELL
MAYBE THE PERSON CAN ANSWER SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS. THAT'S NOT THE
PERSON WHO THEY WANT TO. THE
DAY- YOU KNOW THEY HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH SO I THINK IT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT WE LOOK AT
THAT IF WE'RE GONNA TRY TO GET A
VACCINATION RATES UP. NO FRANKLY
FOR MYSELF. I KNOW WHAT THE
VALUE VACCINE IS I JUST TAKE MY
CHILD TO A YOU KNOW TO A TO A
MASS VACCINATION SITE OR
PHARMACY OR WHATEVER THAT'S FINE
BUT THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF OTHER
FAMILIES WHO DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT SO- SO
HOPEFULLY WE'RE REALLY LOOKING
AT THAT- THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE. IS- A NOTE THAT- IS ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED MILLION ALL FIVE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE POINT TWO
MILLION SO. IS ROUNDING UP A
LITTLE BIT. FOR STATEWIDE
TESTING. AND I GUESS THIS
QUESTION IS RELATED TO- ELSE
CERTAINLY SCHOOLS HAVE TO DO ARE
YOU KNOW. DOING A LOT OF TESTING
TO KEEP THE SCHOOLS OPEN- AND- I
UNDERSTAND THAT. THERE'S FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT WENT TO THE
SCHOOLS. THROUGH THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN. BUT THAT SEVERAL
FUNDING- ACTUALLY EXPIRES IN
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO
PERHAPS BECAUSE THAT'S JUNE AND
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR THIS YEAR
STARTING JULY PERHAPS MEDIO
DRESS IN THE MAIN BUDGET. BUT I
AM CURIOUS AS TO- IN TERMS OF
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS WHETHER ANY
OF THE STATEWIDE TESTING MONEY
IS ALSO FOR SCHOOLS OR ARE WE
ACTUALLY ON. A WEAK SEATING
EARLIER UNDER IN TERMS OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT FOR SCHOOL
TESTING. IN TERMS OF THE
SPENDING AND- AND A REAL
DISSIPATING WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
PUT MORE FUNDING OR WE GET MORE
FEDERAL FUNDING SINCE THE
EXISTING FUNDING ENDS IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO I KNOW
WHETHER ANY OF THIS STATEWIDE
TESTING FUNDS. IS TO AUGMENT THE
AMOUNT THAT'S GOING TO SCHOOLS
OR PERHAPS SCHOOLS ARE NOT
SPENDING ALL THAT MONEY SO WE
DON'T NEED TO DO THAT BUT WE'LL
BE ADDRESSING THAT AND- ACTED IN
. IN THE MAIN BY THAT'S IN JULY
FIRST- SO PERHAPS CAN GIVE ME AN
UPDATE AS TO WHERE WE ARE. ON
SCHOOL TED FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
TESTING- THAT- I THINK IT WAS
GIVEN THROUGH THE NIELSEN GRANT
MECHANISM SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
OUR SCHOOLS OPEN. OUR TO LEARN
IT GO AHEAD. SORRY I CAN'T BE
PARKING IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M WE CAN CERTAINLY GET
BACK TO YOU WITH THAT THE BREAK
OUT OF SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN FUN I'M
I AM THE- RESOURCES POLITICS ARE
ALL- WE DO HAVE A EIGHT AND
NINETY NINE AND- BE FINE- UP
FUNDS THAT WERE PROVIDED FOR
PASSING. AND THERE ARE AND BE AT
THE HAVE BEEN- REQUEST THAT YOU
AT TESTING AND AT LIKE THAT WE
WERE HAPPY PROVIDE BREAK UP YOU
OKAY YES YOU COULD GET BACK TO
THEM I WILL BE SURE HAVE ENOUGH
FUN FIRST TESTING KEEPERS OPEN
RIGHT AND- SO I KNOW THEY WERE
FEDERAL. I DON'T KNOW IS FOR
EXAMPLE ARE WE ABOUT HOW IS THAT
IT WAS AND MONEY WAS THAT ENOUGH
AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE TO PUT
SOME THAT MIGHT TO. THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT WE TRACK RATE BECAUSE
THEY ALL THAT'S GOING TO THEN IF
HOME WE MIGHT NEED TO BUDGET. IN
YOU KNOW FOR THE- IT'S FOR THE
MAIN BUDGETS. IN JULY. BECAUSE
IF THIS FEDERAL FUNDING ENDS ON
JUNE TWO. TWENTY TWO- WE NEED TO
KNOW. WAS THAT AND- IS THAT NOT
ENOUGH HOW MUCH WE'RE GET THE
BUDGET. SUB THE- TO. INSURE THAT
WE KEEP OUR SCHOOL OPEN. AND- AS
MUCH AS SOMETHING WOULD WISH IT
AND CERTAINLY I. WISH BUT I. WE
ALL. IS THE CODES. GOING TO. SO
WE NEED TO BE SURE WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT. FOR A SCHOOL. TEST
TO ENSURE THAT- CAN KEEP OUR
SCHOOLS. AND SO I APPRECIATED I
CAN GET BACK SO WE CAN
UNDERSTAND. IF ANY OF THIS. NOW
ARE WE HAD A BEHIND AND IF WE'RE
ARE BEHIND YOU KNOW HAT PORTION
OF THE- FIVE HUNDRED NIGHT.
NIGHT NOT FIVE HUNDRED NINETY
NINE POINT TWO MILLION WOULD BE
NECESSARY TO BE SURE WE AUGMENT
SCHOOL. FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
TESTING TO ENSURE THAT- THE
SUFFICIENT TESTING. THE KEEPER
SCHOOLS OPEN THANK YOU. IN
CENTER OF HANNAH ANDERSON TO
NOTE THAT THE CURRENT. BUDGET
ACTS. DOES INCLUDE SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION SO THAT. HI
MY NAME IS THAT ON TOP OF THAT.
AND TO ACTIVISTS. OR THE-
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
ANOTHER THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION FOR STATEWIDE TESTING
WE'LL GET TO THE BREAKDOWN OF
REGARDS TO YOUR QUESTION BUT
JUST WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW
ABOUT THE SIGNIFICANT-
INVESTMENT FOR STATEWIDE TESTING
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN. THE
CURRENT YEAR AND THE BUDGET YOUR
AXE. YEAH AND I'M CERTAINLY NOT
SAYING THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HASN'T PUT SUFFICIENT HASN'T PUT
SIGNIFICANT MONEY QUESTIONS HOW
MUCH ARE OF IT WERE EXPANDING.
SO THERE'S THIS IS THE OVERSIGHT
PART AND I THINK IT'S OUR- IS S.
AS MY GOOD FRIENDS ARE CORTESE
LIKE. WHAT OKAY FINE WE HAVE
MONEY. HOW MUCH OF IT WE
SPENDING THERE HOW MUCH WHAT WE
NEED. GOING INTO THE FUTURE SO.
THAT'S REALLY THE THRUST OF THE
QUESTION IS NOT THAT. WE HAVEN'T
BUDGETED. DIVISIONS YOU KNOW THE
AMOUNT OF TIMES WE JUST DON'T
KNOW IS THAT SUFFICIENT IS IT.
MORE IS IT LASTS YOU KNOW WHERE
ARE WE RIGHT NOW. AND SO
THEREFORE AND- BECAUSE THESE ARE
IMPORTANT THINGS. THAT WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO FIND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A DOCTOR PAN. WE WILL
NOW TURN TO SENATOR. THANK YOU
MAN CHAIR OF IDEA FULLY SUPPORT
ALL THE BILLS BEFORE US TODAY I
THINK THEY'RE ALL IN COMBINATION
VERY IMPORTANT FORUM FOR OUR
STATE- AND IN PARTICULAR FOR THE
OF SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE-
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY A VERY
EFFICIENT AND IMPORTANT WAY OF.
STOPPING OR THE SPREAD OR
SLOWING DOWN THE SPREAD OF
COALBED IS- HOW WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
STAY HOME THE RIGHT TO STAY HOME
AND STILL NOT LOSE THEIR PAY- I
WILL JUST RAISE UP AN OLD NOT A
QUESTION BUT A COMMENT THAT I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
BUDGET STAFF. ON HOW DO WE
PROVIDE THE SAME ECONOMIC RELIEF
OFFER SMALLER BUSINESSES UNDER
TWENTY SIX- EMPLOYEES- I THINK
THOUGH THEY ARE THE ONES I THINK
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE IN
GREAT GREAT NEED- AND CERTAINLY
THE PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR THEM.
ARE IN GREAT NEED- WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS- ALL THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES UNDER THE AND YET
THEY MAKE UP ALL TOGETHER ABOUT
FOUR MILLION WORKERS SO- I THINK
WE NEED TO BE MORE EXPLICIT AND
TARGETED WITH THE ECONOMIC
RELIEF FOR THE BUSINESSES AS
MUCH AS- THE- WORK MEN AND WOMEN
WHO WORK FOR THEM. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
DRUGS SO- I MAYBE MAKING SOME
COMMENTS ON ON SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS WHEN- BUT I'LL WAIT
TILL I HAVE OTHER SENATORS WHO
AFTER. MIKE'S UP- AND I HAVE A
SENATOR CAFIERO FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR NIELSEN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR COM LOCK. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I TOO WILL BE
SUPPORTING ALL OF A- THESE ITEMS
AND- WANT I. REALLY EMPHASIZE
THE IMPORTANCE TO HAVE THIS
EARLY ACTION IS REALLY IMPORTANT
I DO HAVE A- ONE ISSUE. THAT ARE
HAS BEEN RAISED TO ME AND I
FRANKLY HAD JUST DIDN'T CATCH
IT- IT IS ON AB EIGHTY SEVEN N.
AND THIS IS THE- THIS IS THE M.
THE BILL THAT WOULD- DO A NUMBER
OF THINGS AND IN TERMS OF OUR
SMALL BUSINESS GRANT PROGRAM.
PUMP AS AS EVERYBODY WILL
REMEMBER WE DID DO SOME TAX
CONFORMITY WITH THE FEDERAL.
GOVERNMENT IN REGARDS TO- MAKING
SURE THAT SMALL BUSINESSES THAT.
RECEIVED RELIEF. FROM FROM OUR
GRANT PROGRAM OR RELIEF BECAUSE
OF OUR GRANT PROGRAM OR THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM THAT THEY WOULD
BE TAX BECAUSE OF. ON TOP OF
THAT THOSE GRANT PROGRAMS- THIS
BILL BASICALLY LEAVES A GAP- AND
THE GAP IS BETWEEN MARCH. OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO JUNE OF
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO
IF YOU GOT A GRANT- EITHER FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR FROM
THE STATE GOVERNMENT- OURS OUR
GRANDFATHERS WERE LOANS- YOU HAD
TO PAY TAXES YOU HAVE TO PAY
TAXES ON THEM AND SO- WE DID TAX
CONFORMITY BUT WE DID IT. BEFORE
THAT FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT
EXTENDED THEIR PROGRAM AND SO
WE'VE LEFT THE GAP BECAUSE OF
THIS BILL AND I JUST WANT TO
IDENTIFY IT- WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING TO FIX IT BECAUSE
OTHERWISE. OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE STILL STRUGGLING TO
RECOVER AGAIN AND OF HAVING TO
PAY IF YOU IF YOU WERE UNLUCKY
ENOUGH TO GET THE GRANT BETWEEN.
MARCH AND JUNE OF LAST YEAR THAN
THEN. YOU DO NOT HAVE TAX
CONFORMITY SO I JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT FOR THE RECORD AND SEE
IF WE CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
. FARM DEPARTMENT FINANCE YOU
WANNA RESPOND AT ALL. I JUST
APPRECIATE THAT INFORMATION I
WILL TAKE THAT BACK THANK YOU
SENATOR CABALLERO. RIGHT SENATOR
KABIR DID YOU HAVE ANYTHING ELSE
NO THANK YOU MANAGER I'M GOOD.
OUR SENATOR NELSON. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. YOU KNOW I. THE
MOST TO VOTE NO ON MOLLY'S
PROVISIONS. TO GET A LITTLE BIT
WARY OF THE ADMINISTRATION
USURPING LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
OF COMPROMISING THE PROCESS. IN
RUNNING GOVERNMENT BY EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND NO BID CONTRACTS.
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT CAME IN
WITH THE LATE EDITION. THAT WE
REALLY DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO
THOROUGHLY REVIEW. IT'S
FORGIVENESS OF THESE CERTAIN
LOANS. AND THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTS ONE POINT NINE BILLION.
MORE FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FINANCES THAT THE ONLY WRITTEN
AMOUNT OF RISK THAT- THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT ONE POINT NINE
BILLION. AND WOULD YOU HAVE TO
COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE YOU
MEANING DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE GOVERNOR. TWO SIX SECURE
FUNDING AUTHORITY ARE YOU JUST
ASSUMING THAT YOU HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY TODAY DO YOU OR DO YOU
NOT HAVE THAT AUTHORITY TODAY.
SEVEN METERN INSTEAD I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING ABOUT THE- THE
LANGUAGE THAT PROVIDES- A CASH
FLOW LOAN YEAH. LOOK OKAY-
WITHIN THAT THE LANGUAGE THERE
IS- A CLAUSE THAT ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LOAN FORGIVENESS
SHOULD THE FEDERAL FUNDS. NOT
COME IN WITHIN. WHEN HE SO THE
END OF THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR. THE
BILL HAS THE AUTHORITY APARTMENT
TO PROVIDE LOANS FOR STATE LOCAL
RENTAL ASSISTANCE. BUT THE BILL
DOESN'T INCLUDE AN APPROPRIATION
WHEN WILL THAT APPROPRIATIONS BE
PUT INTO THE BUDGET. SECRETARY
RETIRED CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU WELL I WE CAN ALSO
ASK THE LEDGE ANALYST OR MAYBE
THE CONTROLLER. BUT THESE LOANS
. FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE. BUT THE
ON LOAN AND I'M SORRY I THANK I
CAN BE A TO ADDRESS THAT I WAS
TO HEARING THE REST OF YOUR- BUT
I BELIEVE YOU'RE ASKING AGAIN
ABOUT THE RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
PROGRAM AND JUST THIS IS A CASH
FLOW LOAN AND SO THERE THERE
ISN'T AN APPROPRIATION REQUIRED
AT THIS MOMENT- I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL REALLOCATED FUNDS
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM. IT'S A
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM THAT-ABOUT- THAT WAS CREATED AS PART
OF- FEDERAL STIMULUS PACKAGES
AND WE CONTINUE TO- ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE AS WELL AS
LOCALS TO PROVIDE US FINE. I'M
SORRY. THIS LONG IS A FOR. TO A
THESE TO CONTINUE THAT THE STATE
LEVEL AND AT THE LOCAL LOCAL
LEVEL SO THAT CALIFORNIANS
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS CAN
CONTINUE TO PURSUE PAYMENT. WELL
YOU KNOW WHAT'S INTERESTING IS.
WHAT ASSURANCE DO WE HAVE THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS GOING
TO COME THROUGH WITH ANY FUNDING
I DON'T THINK WE DO WHERE YOU'RE
MAKING GROSS ASSUMPTIONS HERE.
AND THAT THAT THERE WOULD BE
FEDERAL MONEY. WHO IS A BLIGE OF
THAT FEDERAL MONEY DOES NOT COME
TO COVER THE LOANS THAT THE
STATE HAS PROVIDED WHERE WILL
THAT MONEY COME FROM. AGAIN THIS
IS A CASH FLOW LOAN TO BRIDGE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO SPEAK WITH-
THE TREASURY WE HAVE- A MULTI
STATE LETTER. TO FOR THEIR
SUPPORT I REQUEST AS WELL AS OUR
TWO U. S. SENATORS- SO WE ARE
PUSHING AGGRESSIVELY FOR.
THROUGH A FEDERAL ADVOCACY FOR
THOSE FUNDS. WELL IT'S A PART OF
THE GAMESMANSHIP THAT DOES
BECOME RAMPANT NOW IN OUR BUDGET
. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES GUILTY
FOR A LOT OF THE SENATE HAPPENED
OVER MANY YEARS. IT'S JUST THAT
I'M GETTING A LITTLE TIRED OF IT
. THE BILL SAYS THAT THE BEST
GENERAL WOULD NOT COUNT AS A
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE. BUT
WE'VE GOT OVER A BILLION DOLLARS
THE DRESS CARE. WE MIGHT NOT GET
IT BACK. CAN'T THAT MAKE MUCH
THAT NOT BE CONSIDERED AN
EXPENDITURE ORDER YOU JUST
DESCRIBED IS THAT YOUR WAY OF
THE GROUND THE BEGAN LIMIT OR
SOMETHING IS THAT WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TRYING TO DO
SKATE THE GAMUT. NO SENATOR- IT
BECAUSE IT IS A CASH ALONE IT IS
NOT CONSIDERED APPROPRIATIONS
SAID THAT LONG BEFORE GIVEN IN
THE FUTURE THAT THE ALLOCATION
WOULD OCCUR AT THAT TIME. PLEASE
DO NOT FEEL THAT THIS IS A
PERSONAL ONE IN ANY WAY. AND
THAT'S HAPPENED OVER MANY YEARS
AND I'VE PROBABLY HAD TO DEAL
WITH MORE THAN MOST BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN HERE A LOT OF YEARS. BUT
I'M GETTING WARY OF IT. AND I
GET A LITTLE BIT MORE CLOSER FOR
US IN MY COMPLAINT. ABOUT AND WE
JUST DON'T KNOW IT'S A BLANK
CHECK. IN THE GOVERNOR USURPED
AUTHORITY ALL THE TIME. WHEN ARE
SOME OF THESE EMERGENCY POWERS
GOING TO BE EXTINGUISHED IF THE-
VILLA SHOWS THE GOVERNOR
CONTINUES HE EMERGENCY POWERS.
THAT COULD EXTEND INTO THE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THAT'S A
LONG TIME OFF SO IS THE GOVERNOR
GOING TO EVER IT EXTINGUISH THE
EMERGENCY AUTHORITY THERE'S A
AND WHAT IS HIS PLAN. YEAH I
WOULD JUST POINT TO THE FACT
THAT WE ARE COMING TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR EARLY ACTION ON
KOBE IT AS AN EXAMPLE WELL WHICH
WAS- BUT INITIALLY WE HAD A
FORTY THROUGH- STATUTE THROUGH
JERRY ELLIS STATUTES TO. SPEND
AND OUT OF THE- AS OF THE U. WE
FIVE NO LONGER HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY NO LONGER THE
FLEXIBILITY TO USE THAT TRIO UP
FRONT AND SO AS AN EXAMPLE WE
ARE COMING BEFORE. THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ASK FOR THOSE
ADDITIONAL FINES- THROUGH THE
CONTROL SECTION WE ALSO HAVE- A
MEASURE OF AN ABILITY TO THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE WE HAVE A
TEN DAY NOTIFICATION TO THE GLVC
BEFORE WE CAN EXPAND THE SPOT.
SO JUST TO POINT OUT SOME OF
THAT. THE BALANCE THERE. WE FORM
DOES IT TAKE BUDGET BUT- AT THE
FOR BRINGS FOR. THE LEGISLATURE
. THE KOBE REQUEST RELATED THAT
WOULD BE THROUGH A JAIL LET. AND
SO THAT WOULD BE A EDUCATION
STUDER- THE FIRE TO THE
EXPENDITURE OF A OF THOSE FINE
FOR WHICH WERE OUT FOR- IN THE
IN CURRENT YEAR. WELL THE GUN
SEEMS TO HAVE A- PENSION FOR
NOBODY CONTRACTS. AND I THAT'S A
BIT OF A- IS A BIT OF BECAUSE
IT'S BECOMING. A COMMON. N. I AM
INFORMED THAT EIGHTY TWO MILLION
APPROPRIATED HERE FOR THE
TROUBLED BLANCHARD BRANCH
TESTING LABORATORY WILL NEXT
FIVE MONTHS TO CONTINUE THE
MONTH TO MONTH THE FUNDING. THIS
NO BID CONTRACT- THE COMPANY
CALLED PERKINS ELMER. NOW
INVESTIGATORS HAVE FOUND PERKINS
OUR HAVING BEEN OUT OF
COMPLIANCE. THE LABORATORY RULES
STATE AND FEDERAL. AND THAT I'VE
BEEN INFORMED THAT THEIR CHECK
CHEAPER AND QUICKER TESTING
ALTERNATIVES THAT EXIST. IT ARE
YOU LOOKING AT THOSE OTHER
OPTIONS OR WE JUST GONNA
CONTINUE DOWN THIS PATH WITH THE
CONTRACT WITH PERKINS ELMER.
WHAT ARE THE CHECKS AND BALANCES
IN THE CONTROL TO FINANCING
POSES TO ENSURE THAT. SERVICES
ARE DELIVERED. YES AND AT A HIGH
LEVEL AGAIN THAT'S- THAT
CONTRACT MAY BE TERMINATED WITH-
I BELIEVE SIXTY DAYS NOTICE PROP
THIRTY DAYS NOTICE- IN REGARDS
TO THEIR PERFORMANCE SO THERE IS
THAT MEASURE OF. ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT THE STATE HAS BUT I WILL
TURNS QUESTION NUMBER FOR MORE
DETAILS TO- AS FAR. THANK YOU I
THINK ON OF THE- FINANCE LET ME
- THANK GOD PLEASE. HAVE THERE'S
NO ONE ALLOW- WE ARE IN THE- BY
LOOKING AT ALTERNATE- THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT HIGHLAND-
PROGRAM WITH THE OF CALIFORNIA-
BUT TO THIS POINT- LONG IS
ACROSS COME. OF OUR PROGRAM.
EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC BY J. WHEN
OUR STRETCH- BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE Y. WERE CONTENDING FOR
SCARE RESOURCES. AND ALLOW.
ALLOWED US. INTRO ARE OWN
TESTING. THAT THE STATE NOT A
PART WHO IS UNIQUELY. TO ADDRESS
ONGOING SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES. THE
VENDOR PERKINELMER WAS SELECTED
BECAUSE TEY HAVE THEIR OWN
EQUIPMENT AND WERE ABLE TO
PRODUCE THEIR OWN HAS
INTENSIFIED. NUMBER CONTROL OVER
THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
GUARANTEEING THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO- PROVIDE ALL NECESSARY
COMPONENTS FOR TESTING. ONE PILL
LABORATORY HAS INCREASED TESTING
AVAILABILITY AND COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE AT HIGHER RISK THAN
CONCRETE CARE SETTING. AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. SO THEY
WITH- A CRANBERRY AND THE DAILY
CASE RATE INCREASE- TESTING
VOLUMES CONTINUE TO BE HIGH
ANOTHER ABOUT THE NEED FOR THE
LAB CONTINUES- BUT AGAIN AS WE
ARE STILL EXPLORING
ALTERNATIVES- BUT AT THIS AT
THIS STAGE YEAH LEVEL ONCE THE
LAB IS STILL A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THE TESTING PROGRAM
. ANOTHER QUESTION. THE HAS BILL
CONTAINS EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A NEW CONTRACT
TRACING EFFORTS. INCLUDING A NEW
PROGRAM TO DIVERT EXISTING STAFF
STATIC STATE P. WISE I GATHER
THAT WHAT THAT WHAT THAT AMOUNTS
TO PERSONAL YEARS STATE STAFF TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH RESERVE CORPS
. TO DO CONTRACT TRACING. NOW
HOW EFFECTIVE RICHEST CONTRACT
TRACING AT STOPPING THE PREAD
OF COLON ARE YOU LOOKING INTO
THAT IS IT WORTH EVEN CONTINUING
THIS EFFORT- HOW DO YOU THEN
HAVE PROTOCOLS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND IF IT'S NOT
WORKING TO TERMINATE THE
CONTRACT OVER THEIR PENALTIES TO
THE CONTRACTOR IF THEY DON'T
DELIVER. AGAIN I RECORD FROM THE
FINANCE AS A CONTACT THEME-
INITIATIVE FOR EIGHTEEN MILLION
IS FOR A VOLUNTEER STATE-
RESERVE CORPS AND THE FINAL FOR
THIS PROGRAM THAT WOULD ONLY BE
UTILIZED IF THEIR WIVES- I NEED
TO- TO INITIATERSU ACTIVATED
FOR THEIR CAR SO IF. THERE IS
NOT A NEED. FIND GOOD RESULT IN
SAVING- SO IT IS CONTINGENT UPON
THE NECESSITY FOR CONTACTING.
JUST DO A GENERAL QUESTION IS
PROBABLY BETTER SERVED WITH
GENERAL SERVICES WHO I THINK
PRIMARILY THE CONTRACTING BUT-
DO OUR CONTRACTS WITH VENDORS
HAVE DELIVERABLES. TIME CERTAIN
SCHEDULES FOR DELIVERY OF
SERVICES AND OR PENALTIES
AGAINST THE CONTRACTOR IF THEY
DO NOT DELIVER. TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT AND
SCRUTINY OF THESE CONTRACTS. HOW
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION KEEP
TRACK- YES SENATOR ALFIE BROADLY
IN REGARDS TO PROCUREMENT AND
CONTRACTS GENERALLY THAT THERE
ARE OFTEN DELIVERABLE BASED
CONTRACTS THAT THAT THE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
ARE AND OR OTHER DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE HOLDING OF THOSE
PROCUREMENTS WITHIN THOSE
CONTRACTS WITH OF VENDORS
GENERALLY HAVE- MILESTONES THAT
NEED TO BE MAD OR AT SOME SORT
OF DELIVERABLE I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THE SPECIFIC CONTRACT THAT- MISS
CLARK WAS TALKING ABOUT BUT
GENERALLY IF THAT IS THE LEVEL
OF ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE HAVE.
AT THE STATE LEVEL TO- ENSURED
THAT WE ARE GETTING WHAT WE- ARE
. DO YOU EVER THEN THEY HAVE A
IN A PENALTY. IF THEY DIDN'T
DELIVER AGAIN PART TO
DIFFERENTLY THERE MY BE A FINE
PLANNER PENALTY OR SOMEWHERE
HOLD WITH. CAME BUT THAT'S
THAT'S AGAIN GEN- EACH CAR. IS
TO BASED ON THE NEEDS BUT THAT
STATE AS IS ALWAYS LOOKING OUT
FOR THE IT'S- IT'S OFTEN IN
REGARDS TO HOW WE CAN- INCENT
BETTER PERFORMANCE FROM THE
SENATE. WELL JUST FOR THE MOMENT
ALLOW TO OBSERVE. I BELIEVE THE
PER SHOULD BE RIGHT INDIGNANT
AND CONCERNED IN THE PRESS
SHOULD BE EXTRAORDINARILY.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SECRETIVE
GOVERNMENT THAT WE NOW HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THE LACK OF
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF
THE AGENCIES OF STATE GOVERNMENT
AND HOW THEY RUN ROUGHSHOD AND
HOW DO WE BUILD OUR BUDGETS IN A
LOT OF TIMES IT HAPPENS AT THE
LAST MINUTE WITH THE LEGISLATURE
BARELY GET. THE TIME TO REVIEW
THE LANGUAGE IT COMES TO US AND
WE JUST HAVE TO ASSUME. I DON'T
THINK WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO
BUSINESS THAT WAY. THAT PROBABLY
THE GREATEST EXAMPLE OF WHERE WE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
SQUANDERED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ONE OF WHICH IS HIGH SPEED RAIL
BUT THE BIGGEST IS TO HIGH TECH
. THE LAST TWO MEETINGS HERE
WE'VE HAD TO INTERRUPT AND SIT
AROUND AND TWIDDLE OUR THUMBS.
WHILE COMMUNICATION HAD TO BE.
TOWED UP I GUESS. TO ME THAT'S
REALLY AN EMBARRASSMENT TO SERVE
IN THE LEGISLATURE AND HAVE TO
BE SITTING AROUND HERE WELL TECH
PEOPLE COME SWARMING IN THE- SIX
JUST TO BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE.
REMOTE OR IN ANY OTHER WAY. AND
THEN WHEN DID WE GET INTO THESE
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR.
EXPENDITURES LIKE FISCAL. AND
THE CREATION BURKE. EDT YOU NAME
IT OVER THE DECADES- BEEN
SEVERAL. I JUST ADMONISHED THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. EXERT A LOT MORE
OVERSIGHT. AND IMPOSE A LOT MORE
CONSEQUENCES IF WE CANNOT LEAVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
ADMINISTRATION THEN THE
LEGISLATURE CANNOT GET IT RIGHT. THANK YOU I'M SENATOR NELSON I
HAVE SENATOR COM LOGGER AND
SENATOR DOLLY ON THE LIST I'M
GONNA MAKE A FEW COMMENTS BEFORE
I CALLING YOU BOTH THEN WE WILL
IF I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER MIKES
UP WE WILL THEN GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. SO THAT WE CAN MANAGE
TO VOTE BEFORE- ARE TWELVE
THIRTY DEADLINE- COUPLE OF
POINTS I JUST WANT TO MAKE. THE
CLEARLY- OF I SURE NIELSEN
HEARINGS LIKE THIS OR THE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR YOU AND ALL OF
US TO MAKE OUR VIEWS KNOWN WHICH
YOU- YOU DID HI AND THE BUT I
DID WANT TO NOTE ONE KEY THING
IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THE
EXPENDITURES AND THEIR RELATED
TO COPE IT. THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE
HAVE GONE THROUGH THE JAIL BC-
PROCESS HOWEVER AS THE
LEGISLATURE WE AND BOTH HOUSES
WE BASICALLY SAID NO THEY SHOULD
GO THROUGH OUR BUDGET PROCESS
THEY SHOULD HAVE A HEARING SUCH
AS THIS THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
BE VETTED BY OUR LEGISLATIVE
COLLEAGUES ARE STAFF AND OF
COURSE THE PUBLIC AND THAT IS
WHY. WE HAVE THE BEFORE US AND
WHY WE HAVE THIS HEARING BUT
WHAT I WOULD NOTE IS THAT IN
RELATIONSHIP TO A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. WE ARE CURRENTLY AT.
OR IT.PER DAY. COVERT DATA AS-
AS WE DID A YEAR AGO. SO FOR
ANYONE TO IMAGINE THAT WE ARE
NOT IN A STATE OF EMERGENCY
STILL FROM THIS PANDEMIC WHILE
WE ARE ALL TIRED OF IT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE STILL IN
A STATE OF EMERGENCY AND WE
HAVE. AS I SAID. THAT WERE ABOVE
THE NUMBER OF DEATHS PER DAY IN
THE STATE AS WE DID A YEAR AGO.
SO I THINK ALL OF US WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR WE CONTINUE
TO BE AS SMART. AROUND OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTOCOLS TO
MINIMIZE THOSE DEATHS AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT WHETHER IT'S BUSINESSES
ARE STATE AGENCIES ARE PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS OR WHAT HAVE
YOU. AND IN RELATIONSHIP TO-
FUNDING FOR SUCH THINGS AS CDCR
WHILE I WOULD- HOPE THAT WE GOT
TO THE POINT. IF WE LOOK AT FOR
EXAMPLE THE U. S. MILITARY
WHERE- THERE'S NOW CONSEQUENCES
TO THOSE- MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT
VACCINATED. THAT WE MIGHT GET TO
SUCH ACIRCUMSTANCE IN OUR OWN
AMONGST MANY OF OUR OWN STAFF
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT SERVE
CONGREGATE SETTINGS BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY. THEY ARE PUTTING
THE. THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS BUT WE ARE IN THIS CASE
ADDRESSING IT WITH TESTING AND
CONTINUED- PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT ALSO AND
THEN I WANTED TO ADD ON THE-
ISSUES OF THE ASSISTANT STORE
LANDLORDS IN OUR TENANTS. IT IS
YOUR ACCURATE THAT THE WE ARE
NOT GUARANTEED THAT WE WILL
RECEIVE THE FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
WE HOPE HOWEVER THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. HAS MADE IT CLEAR
BOTH IN THE INITIATION OF THE
PROGRAM AND SUBSEQUENTLY THAT.
IN THEY MADE AN INITIAL
ALLOCATION TO STATES BUT THAT
THEY WOULD BE SWEEPING THE
UNSPENT MONEY FOR MANY STATES
WHO DID NOT SPEND THEIR MONEY
AND RE ALLOCATING AND WE ALREADY
KNOW IT'S WELL DOCUMENTED
PUBLICLY THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF STATES A GOOD NUMBER THAT DID
NOT SPEND THEIR FULL AMOUNTS OR
SOME CASE VERY LITTLE. AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO
BE REDISTRIBUTING THAT AND GIVEN
THE NUMBER OF THE LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO QUALIFY FOR THAT
PROGRAM IN WHO HAVE SUBMITTED
APPLICATIONS WE NEED TO DO OUR
VERY VERY BEST. TO PURSUE
GETTING THAT MONEY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO SUPPORT
THAT BECAUSE WE DO NOT NEED TO
SEE EITHER OUR SMALL SMALL
LANDLORDS HURT. DUE TO LACK OF
THE ABILITY OF THEIR TENANTS TO
PAY NOR DO WE NEED TO SEE A LOT
OF EVICTIONS OCCUR. ON AT SOME
POINT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS
AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN THE
STATE. SO I WANTED TO MAKE JUST
A COUPLE OF THOSE POINTS I HAD
SOME OTHERS I WANTED TO MAKE
AROUND SMALL BUSINESSES- BUT I-
BECAUSE I DO NOTE- SENATOR DRUGS
IS CONCERNED THAT. WHILE IT I
THINK WE HAD IN OUR NEGOTIATIONS
AROUND MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS NOT
JUST THE ONES THAT ARE BEFORE US
TODAY WE OFTEN EXEMPT THE SMALL
EMPLOYERS. FROM BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE THE KIND
OF REVENUE IN GENERAL THAT LARGE
EMPLOYERS HAVE AND SO. THEY HAVE
LESS ABILITY PERHAPS TO COVER
THE TYPES OF COSTS THAT MAY BE
INVOLVED IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF VARIOUS PROGRAMS HOWEVER WE
ALSO KNOW THAT A VERY LARGE
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS DO ARE
EMPLOYED BY SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND THEY NEED THE ASSISTANCE
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
PAID SICK LEAVE TO AND YET IN
THIS CASE WERE NOT NECESSARILY
MANDATING IT BUT- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT MANY OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN THE MOST
HARDEST HIT. BY THE ECONOMIC
REPERCUSSIONS OF THIS PANDEMIC
SO ARE WHILE OUR AND DO ACTIONS
BEFORE US INCLUDE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION MORE. FOR THE
GRANTS TO SMALL BUSINESSES WE
MAY WANT TO LOOK AT WHAT OTHER
VERY TARGETED PROGRAMS WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE. TO ASSESS
BOTH THE EMPLOYEES AND OF SMALL
BUSINESS AND THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THEMSELVES AND WE'RE
TALKING NOW THE VERY SMALL ONES.
MEANING THE TWENTY FIVE OR LESS.
THAT IN MANY CASES WE'VE
ACCEPTED FROM THINGS BUT IT IS
SOMETHING WE DO NEED TO LOOK AT
SINCE THE DATA SHOWS THAT
THERE'D BEEN SOME OF THE HARDEST
HIT. SO THOSE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT CLEARLY YOU'RE ALL OF VIEW
HAVE START THE BUDGET SEPT
HEARINGS YOU'RE DEALING WITH
LOTS OF THESE. ISSUES AND
TODAY'S JUST NEARLY ACTIONS BUT
I WILL BE QUIET NOW. AND
RECOGNIZE SENATOR COM MARKER
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DOLLY AND
THEN WE WILL GO TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT GO AHEAD CENTER COMPLEX.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AM I. IN
THANK YOU FOR THOSE. COMMENTS
THAT YOU SHARED WITH US. I TOO
WILL BE- SUPPORTING THE- ITEMS
BEFORE US WHEN IT IS TIME- FOR
THE VOTES- LATER ON. THEY LATER
ON I WANTED TO JUST SORT OF GO
BACK TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
MADE BY DR PAN ABOUT. IN NEW
ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW WE'VE HIT A
WALL- WITH VACCINATION RATES BUT
WE'VE HIT A WALL FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS- AND- ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE'VE HAD A WALL IS BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE TIRED. YOU KNOW
PATIENTS AND WORKERS AND
FAMILIES ARE BURNED OUT THEY'RE
OVERWHELMED THEY ARE TIRED. AND
SO IT IS GREAT THAT WE ARE
PUTTING ADDITIONAL DOLLARS INTO
YOU KNOW TESTING AN OUT REACH
AND BOOSTERS AND EQUIPMENT IT IS
GREAT THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING ARM
PAID SICK LEAVE. I ALSO HOPE
THAT WHILE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
ECONOMIC RELIEF WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THAT SHOULD ALSO BE
TRANSLATING INTO PSYCHOLOGICAL.
RELIEF IF PEOPLE ARE BURNED OUT
IF THEY ARE DEALING WITH
DEPRESSION IF THEY ARE CHECKING
OUT IN MORE WAYS THAN ONE. THEN
WE WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT OF HOW TO
FACE. AS IT RELATES TO HOW SMALL
BUSINESSES STAY OPEN HOW IT
RELATES TO WORKERS WANTING TO
SHOW UP AND GO TO WORK AS IT
RELATES TO YOUNG PEOPLE WANTING
TO SHOW UP AND GO TO SCHOOL- SO
I AM HOPING THAT SOMEHOW SOME
WAY WHILE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
RELIEF AND COLD WOULD RELIEVE.
THAT WE ARE INSERTING YOU KNOW
MENTAL HEALTH. AND OTHER
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THAT WILL
REQUIRE FUNDING TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE FEELING GOOD.
ABOUT WORKING THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC THAT WE ARE STILL IN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR COM
ORDER I'M- I DON'T WANT TO
PRESUME BUT I'M ASSUMING YOU
DON'T NECESSARILY WANT A
RESPONSE FROM NOT JUST YOU
WANTED TO PUT IT ON THERE AND I
WANTED TO PUT IT ON THE RECORD
WE HAVE TO BE THINKING ABOUT
PEOPLE'S MENTAL HEALTH CAN I
HAVE A BUSINESS OPEN IF NOBODY
SHOWING UP BECAUSE THEY'VE
CHECKED OUT BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
ADDRESSING THOSE ISSUES AS WELL
CERTAINLY THANK YOU. SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I DO HAVE A QUESTION I
WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THE- BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR AND- SO WE'VE
APPROPRIATED THE PROPOSAL IS TO
APPROPRIATE ONE POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS. AND. SENATOR
NELSON ASKED ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
RATE RELIEF I WANT I AND THIS IS
GOING TO GO TO COUNTIES AND THE
AND THEY'RE GONNA DISTRIBUTE OUT
AND IF IT DOESN'T GET. WE DON'T
GET PAID BACK BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IT'S GOING TO COME
OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND IT'S
GOING TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS AND THERE'S GOING
TO HAVE TO BE APPROPRIATIONS IF
THAT. DOESN'T HAPPEN AND THERE'S
NO GUARANTEE THAT THAT WILL
HAPPEN. MY QUESTION IS WHAT IS
THE AMOUNT. THAT WE KNOW. IS ONE
POINT NINE BILLION THE AMOUNT
WHAT IS IT WHAT IS THE AMOUNT
YOU'RE WILLING TO GO. AND PAY
AND RISK TO THE GENERAL FUND I
THAT YOU KNOW. THERE'S NO DETAIL
AND WHAT THE AMOUNT IS. WHAT IS
THAT AMOUNT. ARE YOU SENATORS SO
THE ONE POINT NINE BILLION THAT
SENATOR NIELSEN MENTIONED IS A
NUMBER THAT WE HAVE. REQUESTED
OF THE FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT
THROUGH THE TREASURY- IN REGARDS
THE REALITIES YOU KNOW DOLLARS
THAT- SENATOR SKINNER-
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED. ARE THERE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT HAVE
BEEN UNDERUSED UNSPENT BY OTHER
STATES AND THE TREASURY- HAS A
REALLOCATION PROCESS FOR THOSE
UNSPENT DOLLARS AND SO AS WE-
CONTINUE OUR ADVOCACY THE ONE
POINT NINE BILLION IS. WHAT WE
HAVE ASKED FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- NEXT TO- MEET THE
NEEDS OF ELIGIBLE. FEATURES AND
LANDMARKS. SO IS THAT THE CAP
ONE POINT NINE IS WHAT. IS THE
CAPITAL. THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING
TO GET TO AS WELL AS YOU SAY.
YOU KNOW THIS IS IT IS A LONG IT. AND THERE IS THERE IS NOT AN
AMOUNT. YEAH I LOST YOU THERE AT
THE END THE AMOUNT WAS ONE POINT
NINE. BUT DOES THAT NOT MEAN YOU
CAN SPEND THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IF IT'S AVAILABLE AND WE DON'T
GET ME WRONG- COMPENSATED BACKED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
OUR GENERAL FUND. WOULD BE- HAVE
TO APPROPRIATE THOSE LOANS. BACK
TO THE COUNTIES THAT- OPERATE
THESE RENT RELIEF PROGRAMS. SO
I'LL JUST I WON I WON AND I'M
TRYING TO ASK WHAT'S THE RISK
WHAT'S THE TOTAL RISK THERE IS
NO NUMBER. THE NUMBER IS OPEN
ENDED. A MINUTE MISLI ARE YOU.
APOLOGY CENTER BY I CAN'T HEAR I
CAN'T HEAR YOU HERZL UNLIMITED
IF CAN YOU HEAR ME MISLI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. NO SHE STILL CAN'T OKAY
THERE IS. CAN YOU HEAR ME-
CENTER GOALIE WHILE THEY'RE
TWELVE WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH IT. I
CAN HEAR YOU OKAY GREAT SO
SENATOR LEAHY'S QUESTION IS. IT
IS THIS IS THE CASH FLOW IS THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT IN THE CASH FLOW
THE RISK THAT'S BEING ASSUME TO
NOW OR IS IT HIGHER. YES THE ONE
POINT NINE BILLION WAS- THE
STATE ESTIMATE OF THE QUEUE OF
APPLICATIONS THAT. ARE GOING TO
BE COMING IN THROUGH THE END OF
MARCH. AND MARCH ISN'T AN
IMPORTANT DATE BECAUSE THAT IS
WHEN THE RENTER PROTECTIONS.
THAT ARE INSTRUCTED NOT WOULD
END AND SO THE PROGRAM IS
ATTEMPTING TO. FULFILL THE
OBLIGATIONS OF THE APPLICATIONS
THAT COME IN. TO THAT POINT THAT
IS THE ONE POINT NINE BILLION
THAT WOULD THAT IS UNDER
DISCUSSION AT THIS POINT. I
UNDERSTAND THAT MY QUESTION WAS
IS IT. THREE BILLION DOLLARS
CAME IN IN. WHAT DO YOU DOES
THIS AGAIN DOES THIS ALLOW TO
SPEND MORE THAN ONE POINT NINE
MILLION WHAT IS THE CAST WHEN
I'M ASKING. BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN.
UNDER THE STATE OF EMERGENCY A
LOT OF THINGS HAPPEN THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE DOESN'T HAVE ANY
INPUT IN IT MAINLY AT LEAST ON.
OUR SIDE OF THE AISLE DOESN'T
SEEM TO HAVE MUCH INPUT IN SO
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE RISK IS. LONG TERM IS-
CAPPERS ARE NO CAP. THAT'S WHAT
I'M ASKING YOU. THERE IS NO CAP
IN THE STATUTE WE DON'T
ANTICIPATED REACHING THREE
BILLION AGAIN WE HAVE AN
ESTIMATE OF ONE POINT NINE
BILLION. AND WE CONTINUED TO
REQUEST FEDERAL FUNDING. OF BACK
OUT. SO YOU ANSWER MY QUESTION
THERE IS NO CAP THAT MEANS THAT
OUR GENERAL FUND IS GOING TO BE.
AT RISK OF WHATEVER AMOUNT THAT
COMES IN AND GETS PAID THANK YOU
FOR THAT ANSWER I HAVE. SOME
COMMENTS NOW THAT I JUST WANTED
TO SHARE WITH THE- LEGISLATURE.
AYE- LET ME IN I DON'T THINK
THAT'S WHAT- MISLI SAID. IT IS A
I THINK SHE AND SHE AND I CAN
LETTER CORRECT BUT- I THINK SHE
INTERPRETED WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS THAT IF THREE BILLION CAME IN
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WHEN I ASKED IF WE- THREE
BILLION OKAY. IT WOULD HAVE I
TRIED TO GET SHE ANSWERED THERE
IS NO CAP SO THAT MEANS IF WE
SPEND. THREE BILLION OR WE LOAN
LET'S PUT IT IN A BETTER TERM WE
LOAN THREE BILLION DOLLARS. THAT
MEANS THAT THE GENERAL FOR IF WE
DID NOT RECEIVE IT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE'RE ON OUR
GENERAL FUND IS GOING TO HAVE TO
PAY THAT AMOUNT WHATEVER THAT
AMOUNT IS A CASH FLOW. LOAN WE
ARE PROVING NOW IS THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT THAT IS BEFORE US. YEAH
THAT'S NOT WHAT SHE SAID. WELL I
HAS OUT THERE IS THERE IS THE
ONE POINT NINE A CAP ON RATE
RELIEF. THERE'S A YES OR NO
EITHER IT IS OR IT ISN'T. WELL
THE LANGUAGE DOES NOT INCLUDE A
CAP THE CAP IS THE ESTIMATE THAT
WE HAVE- PROVIDED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN REGARDS TO THE
STATE MEET. THERE'S NO LANGUAGE
IN THE LANGUAGE IS ONLY FOR A
CASH FLOW LOAN SO IT IS NOT AN
ALLOCATION IT IS ONLY ON A LOAN
IT DOES NOT HAVE AN UP TO NUMBER
BUT IT IS ONLY A CASH FLOW LOAN
SO THERE IS NO ALLOCATION
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. DAN BUT
THERE IS A LIABILITY AND THAT'S
WHAT I WAS TRYING TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE IS A LIABILITY IN
WHATEVER THAT. WHATEVER THE
AMOUNT IS THAT GETS LOAN. IS
LIFE IS THE LIABILITY IF THEY
GIVE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES NOT
. BACKFILL THAT THOSE RESOURCES
THAT YOU'VE ANSWERED MY QUESTION
I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THERE IS NO
CAP. AND WE ARE RISKING WHATEVER
THE AMOUNT IS IT COULD BE ONE
POINT NINE OR IT COULD BE. THREE
BILLION WE DON'T KNOW. BUT I
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THANK YOU.
I'M WE I BEFORE I GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT I WOULD HATE I DON'T
KNOW IT SORRY SENATOR DOLE IF
YOU HAD MORE DO YOU HAVE YES I
DID I WANTED. I WANTED TO SAY.
GUARDS TWO. NO BID CONTRACTS I
THINK THAT'S WHAT. WE'VE BEEN
TALKING WITH OUR SIDE ALVIN
THOMAS ONE SENATOR MELENDEZ IS
BRINGING FORTH. THIS STATE OF
EMERGENCY. AND WE SEE NO BID
CONTRACTS WE'VE SEEN MANY OF
THEM AND THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE NOT
GETTING SCRUTINIZED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE. THEIR LEAD OUT WITH
NO. THERE'S NO R. P. THERE'S NO
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL THESE ARE
JUST CONTRACTS MADE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. LET ME GIVE AN
EXAMPLE. THERE IS A CONTRACT LET
FOR THE SLEEP TRAIN ARENA TO
HAVE COPD PATIENTS GO OUT THERE
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS. NO BID
CONTRACT. THEY SAW NINE PATIENTS
. WE'VE SEEN THE VALENCIA LAB
IT'S NOT PERFORMING AT THE
LEVELS WE WANT WE'VE BEEN INTO
THIS CAN'T PANDEMIC NOW FOR HOW
LONG A LONG TIME. AND IF WE
STAND IN THE STATE EMERGING
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE'RE GONNA
GET OUT OF IT ANYTIME SOON I
THINK IT'S TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO STEP IN AND SAY
NO TO THE GOVERNOR. AND NOTED
THAT MINISTRATION THAT WE WANT
TO SEE THESE CONTRACTS WE WANT
TO SEE PERFORMANCES ON THOSE
CONTRACTS. IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT
WE NEED TO DO OUR JOB BUT WE'VE
IS HE SERVED ALL OF OUR POWER.
TO THE GOVERNOR. TO A GUY WHO
CAN YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. TWO GUYS
WHO CAN SIT IN A BASEBALL OR A
FOOTBALL STADIUM WITH NO MASK ON
UNTIL MY CHILD SHE HAS TO WEAR A
MASK AT SCHOOL. THAT'S THE
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEM HERE THEY
ARE NOT UNDERSTANDING IS NOT
RELATING BACK AND FORTH. SO
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE POLICIES
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE MONEY LET'S
TALK ABOUT HOW WE'RE GETTING
THESE CONTRACTS WE DON'T DO THAT
HERE. WE JUST OPEN ENDED A CAR.
THE BUDGET. TO ALLOW TO SPEND
MONEY THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO PAY BACK IF IT DOESN'T GET
COMMITTEE BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO I THINK THIS IS
THE PLACE WE NEED TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT WE DON'T.
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE THEM.
BECAUSE WE'RE UNDER THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND WE'VE GIVEN ALL
THE POWER OF THIS LEGISLATURE.
AND THIS PARTY. TODAY
MINISTRATION AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT'S THE GOOD OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN IN THIS A
LONG TIME NOW. WE DO A LOT MORE
THAN WE KNEW WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED OUT AND IT'S TIME THAT
WE ACTUALLY DO OUR JOB. AND TAKE
BACK THE POWER. I'M SORRY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. YOU'RE WELCOME.
LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
MIKES UP BEFORE. RIGHT OKAY-
MODERATOR YOU CAN GET READY TO
KEEP FOLKS UP WE'VE GOT SOME
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM BUT BEFORE
THAT I WANT TO SAY. THAT IN MY
HI READ OUR MATERIALS CAREFULLY
I UNDERSTOOD THAT THE
AUTHORIZATION OF A CASH FLOW
LOAN IS PUT IS THAT IS APPROVING
A RISK AND ET AT LEAST ALL HIGH
AND WE AND I- WE WILL SEE BUT I
BELIEVE MY COLLEAGUES TO AGREE.
THAT THE RISK. OF HAVING. PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOW HOUSE ON THE STREET
FOR HAVING SMALL LANDLORDS NOT
BE ABLE TO MEET THEIR
OBLIGATIONS BECAUSE THEY'RE
TENANTS CANNOT PAY THEM IS A
HIGHER RISK IN MY OPINION THEN
THE RISK FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT GIVEN THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
CLEAR THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
REDISTRIBUTING FUNDS NOW I AM
LESS CONCERNED ABOUT ARE. HIGHLY
EXCEEDING THE ESTIMATION THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
GIVEN BECAUSE IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR IT TO PROCESS A
FIGURE SUCH AS THREE BILLION IN
THAT SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
BETWEEN NOW AND MARCH AND THE
ESTIMATE IS BASED ON THE
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE PENDING
AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW THAT IT
IT'S BASED ON SOME REAL DATA
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD THE PROGRAM
OPEN FOR SOME PERIOD OF TIME. ON
SO WHILE WE CERTAINLY HAVE
DIFFERING OPINIONS AS TO WHICH
OF THESE ACTIONS ARE GIVING THE
ADMINISTRATION PERHAPS MORE
THROUGH ALREADY THEN WE SHOULD I
AM VERY CLEAR THAT THE ACTIONS
WE ARE TAKING TODAY ARE BOTH. TO
MY TASTE OR NOT THE CARD US
ACTING TO GIVE THE
ADMINISTRATION THE AUTHORITY.
AND THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
ACTIONS IN HERE LIKE THE COVERED
RELIEF ONES WHERE THEY COULD
HAVE OTHERWISE GONE THROUGH JAIL
BC BUT WE AS THE LEGISLATURE
SAID NO WE WILL. WE ARE NOT
GOING TO ACT ON THEM AND THAT
WAY WE ARE GOING TO DO THIS
THESE HEARINGS AND WE'RE GOING
TO BRING THEM BEFORE US AND WE
ARE GOING TO ACT ON THE FLOOR.
SO I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT
ON THE RECORD AND- WITH THAT WE
WILL GO TO PUBLIC HEARING AND
LET ME HAVE THE FOLKS IN WHO ARE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THEY CAN BEGIN AND
THEN MODERATOR YOU CAN START
KILLING PEOPLE UP RIGHT. PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR I ASSUME ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. YES
OKAY A CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON
BEHALF OF THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY SEVEN THE
ECONOMIC RELIEF MEASURE. WE WANT
TO THANK THE ADMINISTRATION THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE FOR
NOT ONLY THE PROVISIONS OF AB
EIGHTY SEVEN BUT ALSO
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE. OF
GETTING THIS DONE WILL BE LOOK
BEFORE. THE MARCH FIFTEENTH
FILING DEADLINES FOR OF IN THE
STATE OF. IN PART TO THE TO CAN
FOR THE REVIVAL PLAN GRAHAM AS
WELL AS THE SHATTERED VENUE I.
GRANT AND THEN OF THE L.
ELIMINATION OF THE THIRD AND
FINAL YEAR OF THE CAP ON ALL
BUSINESS TAX CREDITS AS WELL AS
THE SUSPENSION OF NET OPERATING
LOSS DEDUCTIONS. FOR BOTH
PERSONAL INCOME TAXPAYERS AND
BUSINESSES I WANTED TO RAISE
WHAT MAY BE A DRAFTING ITEM
RELATED TO THE PASS THROUGH
ENTITY TAX AND THE PROPOSAL TO
ALLOW IT TO REDUCE THE TENTATIVE
MINIMUM TAX BELOW THE REGULAR
TAX. IT APPEARS ALSO FROM YOUR
ANALYSIS THAT'S INTENDED TO
BEGIN. ONE ONE TWENTY ONE
HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME LANGUAGE
IN SECTION SIX OF THE BILL THAT
HAS REFERENCES IN TWO POINTS TO
ONE ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO- SO
WOULD LOVE TO GET VERIFICATION
ON THAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY THAT
WANTS TO ADDRESS US. ON SAYING
NO AND I WOULD. JUST SAY BEFORE
I GO TO THAT TELEPHONE
MODERATOR- THAT WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT UNTIL TWELVE
FIFTEEN I WOULD THEN CUT IT OFF-
SO WE'LL GO NO LATER THAN THAT
SO WE HAVE TIME TO VOTE IN AND
AT TWELVE THIRTY. SELL OUT
MODERATOR COULD YOU- HELPED
BEGIN THE COMMENT FROM MARK.
THOSE WAITING ON THE TELEPHONE.
THANK YOU TO JOIN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT Q. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD IF
YOU HAVE NOT DONE SO ALREADY
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE WILL GO FIRST TO LINE
TWENTY. THE LINE IS OPEN.
MEDICARE MEMBERS MICHAEL YOUNG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTY FOUR ASSEMBLY NOT
THE SICK LEAVE PROVISIONS IN THE
BUDGET OF THE SICKLY DESPITE A
WORKER BENEFIT BUT A VITAL
PUBLIC HEALTH TOOL NECESSARY TO
KEEP WORKPLACES AND COMMUNITY
SAFETY AND OUR ECONOMY GROWING
THE BEST YET STILL- WILL HELP
WORKERS GET THROUGH THE
POTENTIALLY DEVASTATING AND
TECHNICAL THE MATERNAL WORK
HELPING HOLD YOURS LEGISLATURE.
QUICKLY TO ADOPT THESE
PROVISIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. NEXT WE HAVE LINE. TWENTY
THREE. HI KATIE HARTMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
PTA APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR COMMITMENT TO
REINSTATE COVERAGE SICK LEAVE
AND EARLY ACTION ANTI TEACHER
ONLY THE COURT EIGHTY EIGHTY
FOUR THANK YOU. LINE. TWENTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING MY LIVE J. ON
BEHALF OF THE S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHTY FOUR AND
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE IS
QUICK ACTION ON THIS ITEM- IT'S
OF VITAL PUBLIC HEALTH TOOL AND
WORKERS ARE DESPERATE NEED OF.
THE SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. MINE. FORTY HEY AUDREY RETIRED
TECHNICAL STUDIES ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
THEATRE OWNERS THE CALIFORNIA
AND NEVADA THE BOARD OF AB
EIGHTY SEVEN BUT THANK YOU
OPERATOR GRANT PROGRAMS TAX
CONFORMITY. THANK YOU. THANKS
REMIND FORTY FOUR. BUILDING
GREENS OF VIACOM CALIFORNIA WANT
TO THANK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FURTHER ACTION ON AB
EIGHTY SEVEN- COVERED REALLY
SPECIFICALLY ARE INDIAN ANIMAL
RESTORATION ONE YEAR EARLY I
THANK EVERYBODY INVOLVED IN THAT
DOT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE FORTY SIX. HI THIS IS
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES SITUATION
CALLING ON AB EIGHTY SEVEN BUT
THE CALIFORNIA RICH PAYMENT
PROGRAM IN THE CALIFORNIA WATER
WASTEWATER READERS PAYMENT
PROGRAM HAVE HELPED THOUSANDS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ELIGIBLE UTILITY CUSTOMERS WHO
FELL BEHIND THE BILL'S DUE DATE
COULD BE AT ALL WITHIN SIX
MONTHS OF THE PROGRAM BEING
ESTABLISHED WE'RE REALLY
THANKFUL FOR THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP ON BOTH PROGRAMS.
WELL THANKFULLY CALIFORNIA'S
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION TO
RESOLVE ISSUES RELATED TO
PROGRAM BENEFITS AND APPRECIATE
THE CODIFICATION AND HE'D BE
EIGHTY SEVEN THE COSBY PANDEMIC
YOU'VE GOT ARE GOING ON
PREDICTABLE IMPACT EACH OF THE
CUSTOMERS AND- WE LOOK FORWARD
TO DISCUSSIONS HERE ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES TO MEET AND. THAT
NEEDS TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE LINE FORTY SEVEN.
HELLO KEVIN INFO FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTY FOUR KOBE NINETEEN
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SEPARATELY
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTEEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MALIK BYNUM WITH YOU TO
THE ASK ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND ACCESS
AND CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ACROSS
THE STATE ONE EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY EIGHTY FOUR
AND THE EXTENSION OF
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE AS
WELL AB ONE FORTY SEVEN AND THE
FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DISTRIBUTION OF SUPPLEMENTAL
DOLLARS DAMAGE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU. NINE FORTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MINIMUM
ALL RIGHT YOU MONNING WHAT
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY FOUR I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR A COMMENT ON THE
AMOUNT OF DEBT- STILL ONGOING
WITH THE- PANDEMIC. THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY FIVE. KATIE WATER
PLANT BUT THE CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COALITION BEER IN
STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHTY
FOUR OF IN NINETEEN EXACTLY AND-
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR TO ENACT POLICIES THE
PLAY THANK YOU. LINE. FIFTY GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ALEX TOWARDS A STRATEGY THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE EXPECTATION OF
CALIFORNIA MONARCHS PRESS OR
SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHTY SEVEN
INCLUSION OF TAX CONFORMITY FOR
THE SHUTTERED MENU OPERATORS
GRANT WHEN THE BODY PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA VENUES GRANT WE'RE IN
THE FORTUNATE POSITION OF HAVING
TO PAY THE TAXES. ON THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM WITH THE RELIEF MONEY
RECEIVED FROM THE STATE THAT
THAT PROVISION IS MUCH
APPRECIATED- AND. REALLY
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION THANK
YOU. LINE. THIRTY EIGHT. HELLO
OUR PARTNERSHIP CONTRACT JOSE WE
WORK WITH OUR COMMUNITY AND HERE
SEEMS SO MANY PEOPLE RIGHT NOW
WHO CAN'T GET THE BOOST CARE
CAN'T BE WITH THEIR KIDS WHEN
THEY'RE SENT HOME DUE TO COLD
EXPOSURE CAN'T ISOLATE BECAUSE.
BASICALLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR INTRODUCE EIGHT EIGHTY OR
MORE STRONG SUPPORT AND URGE YOU
TO AND WITH DELAY. NEXT WE HAVE
A LINE TWENTY SIX. AFTERNOON
BENTLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION MANY
COMPANIES MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE TAX INCENTIVES
LIMITED BY EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE
AND TWENTY TWENTY ESPECIALLY THE
RD TAX CREDIT WHICH HAS BEEN A
DRIVER OF INNOVATION JOBS AND
REVENUE FOR THE STATE WE BELIEVE
THE RESTORATION OF THESE CREDITS
AND THAT OPERATING LOSSES ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR THE PROGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES. AND FOR
THAT REASON WE ARE THIEVES WORK
EIGHTY EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
WE HAVE LINE FORTY EIGHT OR.
EIGHT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
EDUARDO MARTINEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU- TO
THE COMMITTEE TO THE LEADERSHIP
ON BOTH SIDES AND THE GOVERNOR
FOR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
LINE. EIGHTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR SAYS THERE'S NOT
THAT MANY CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH REGARD TO THE
RESTAURANT REVITALIZATION FUNDS
PROVIDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE FAVORABLE TAX
TREATMENT THESE FUNDS WERE
PROVIDED BY CONGRESS ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS AND THEY'RE
ESSENTIALLY A LIFELINE FOR
RESTAURANTS AND WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE TAX REFORM
ANY PROVISION I WOULD JUST
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE RESTAURANT
REVITALIZATION FUNDS ONLY WENT
2404% OF THE QUALIFIED
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANTS. THAT
MEANS 56% QUALIFIED APPLICANTS
THAT WERE IN LINE GOT NOTHING
WHEN THE FUND YOU BACK RATED
THAT WE WOULD ASK THAT WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO HELP CONGRESS
FINISH THE JOB AND RESTORE THE
FUNDS TO THAT THOSE REMAINING
RESTAURANTS CAN GET SUCH RELIEF
AND AGAIN WE'RE SUPER
APPRECIATIVE OF THE LUCKY FEW
THAT GOT THE RELIEF THAT THEY
WILL BE TREATED FAIRLY ON THE
TAX FRONT AND WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS MADE
EARLIER BY SENATOR COVER YELLOW
WITH REGARD TO EIGHTY SEVEN AND
THE NEED TO ADDRESS A FEW MORE
THINGS IN TERMS OF- TAX
FAIRNESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT WEEK LINE. FIVE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PRESTON YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY
SEVENS REINSTATEMENT OF NET
OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTION TO LOOK
IN THE CATALOG THAT TAX CREDIT.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATORS FOR THE HARD
WORK THAT HAVE GONE INTO THIS-
AND YOU KNOW BUSINESSES OF ALL
SIZES STRUGGLE TREMENDOUSLY
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC DUE TO A
NUMBER OF REASONS. ALLOWING
THESE EMPLOYERS TO UTILIZE NET
OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTIONS WILL
ASSIST IN OFFSETTING THE LOSSES
WHILE STILL CREATING ECONOMIC
RECOVERY FOR THE MORE LIFTING
THE CAP ON BUSINESS INCENTIVE
TAX CREDITS WILL FEEL
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND ALLOW
FOR OUR EMPLOYERS TO CONTINUE TO
TAKE THE LEAD MANY WAYS.
INCLUDING INRESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT WHILE OFFERING HIGH
QUALITY WELL PAYING JOBS TWO
WEEKS SO PLEASE REFER TO SUPPORT. AB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN THANK YOU
. WE HAVE LINE. FOUR GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS STEVE MCCARTHY WOULD BE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
I WANTED TO EXPRESS CONCERN OR
CONCERN THIS MORNING WITH
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY FOUR OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE
MANDATE. WE'VE NOT FORMALLY
ADOPTED THE POSITION BUT ONCE WE
ASK WILL COURSE WITHOUT LETTER
TO YOU BUT JUST DID SOME OF THE
HIGH POINTS- ARE PRIMARY
CONCERNS IS TO PUT IT NATURE OF
THE MANDATE CONTRARY TO THE
POPULAR CREEK TRAIL- THE COULD
BE PAID SICK LEAVE WOULD NOT BE.
THE ONLY PAID LEAVE AVAILABLE TO
EMPLOYEES. WHO CONTRACT COMPANY
NINETEEN. I EMPLOYEES WHO ARE.
TO COVER NINETY NETWORK ARE ALL
ALSO FOR X. PAY. UNDER CAL OSHA
COMPANY. ET LET'S MEASURE.
DIVISIONAL WHERE OF LEAVE ON TOP
WHAT EMPLOYERS ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE. YOU WILL
APPLY WITH EQUALLY CONTRACTED
THE VIRUS OF WORK OR NOT. I'M
ALSO FOR THE PLAYERS A FIVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OR FEWER.
THERE ARE NO FEDERAL TAX CREDITS
AVAILABLE THIS TIME TO HELP
BREAK COSTS. RELATED TO SICK
LEAVE- AND FOR- INDUSTRIES AND
BUSINESSES LIKE RETAIL- WE DO
NOT NECESSARILY BENEFIT FROM THE
R. AND D. TAX CREDIT- PERHAPS SO
MUCH OF FROM THE- IN L.
CREDENTIALED. THIS PACKAGE OF
BILLS AND SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
COSTS FOR EMPLOYERS ON TOP OF
THE ALREADY SUBSTANTIAL EMPLOYER
COSTS RECOVERED COMPLIANCE
INCLUDING. WORKPLACE COMPLIANCE
P. P. AND LIABILITY FOR THE TENS
OF BILLIONS CURRENTLY GO TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THEY'RE
A LITTLE WITH THE MAYOR AND
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY. LINE THIRTY SEVEN. HI THIS IS
JAMIE CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE ASSOCIATED
GENERAL CONTRACTORS OPINION
DIEGO IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY THREE. FORTY THREE YOUR
TELEPHONE DEVICE MAY BE ON YOU.
MOVED ON TO LINE TEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB EIGHTY FOUR RESTAURANTS
FOR THE FIRST TO CLOSE AND IT
WILL BE THE LAST RECOVER FROM
THE COOKIE NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE
WILL NEED A LONG RUNWAY CLEAR OF
ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS IMPOSED TO
PUNISH FOR OUR INDUSTRY TO BE
FULLY RESTORED. UNTIL TODAY
RESTAURANTS ARE FACING A
SHORTAGE OF WORKERS. HI INCREASE
IN LABOR COSTS INCLUDE COSTS AS
WELL AS FOR CLOSURES DUE TO THE
OMICRON VARIANT THE RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY IS DIFFERENT FROM THE
REST OF BUSINESS COMMUNITY WELL
WE HAVE SOMEONE OUT ON PAID SICK
LEAVE YOU HAVE TO PAY AN
ADDITIONAL STOP HER TO COME IN
TELLING THEIR PLACE. I'M
INTENTIONALLY THIS BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY DIRECT TAX CREDIT TO
OFFSET THE COST OF PIZZA CAN YOU
AT THE PREVIOUS BILL HAS DONE
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. LINE FIVE.
WELL GRAYSON LANE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. BLIND. FIFTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS ACTIONS OR
STOP MAYOR CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR AB EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR FOR
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE AND
URGENCY OF THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURE. NINE FIFTY THREE. HI MY
NAME THE THIRTIETH I'M CALLING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LIKE
ASSOCIATION WE ARE INSTRUCTED
FOR AT AB EIGHTY FOUR FAMILIES
THAT ARE COPING WITH THAT CHILD
CARE CLOSURES DUE TO COPE AND
ARE IN DESPERATE NEED OF THAT
EXTRA LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO ENACT IT WITHOUT
DELAY. MAXIS LINE. FIFTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS
STATE FORGES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES AS WELL AS
PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION SOLUTIONS
AND MANAGEMENT WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THE CODE THANK
LANGUAGE THAT WAS INTRODUCED
YESTERDAY BUT WANT TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE TO ENSURE CLARITY
AND CONSISTENCY WITH PREVIOUS
AND EXISTING LEAVE REQUIREMENTS.
EVEN MINISTRATION AND PRO PROPER
PROPER MANAGEMENT OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS THANK YOU. LINE.
NINETEEN AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
NUMBER. JOHNNY PREMIUM WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
TESTIFYING ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
WHAT THAT CONCERN COMMISSION ON
EIGHTY EIGHTY FOUR. WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT HAS
GONE INTO THIS LANGUAGE IS
CRAFTED. BUT WE ARE CONCERNED
WITH SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
CONTAINED IN AB EIGHTY FOUR.
EVEN MORE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS
AND COSTS TO PUBLIC EMPLOYERS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THAT
TOO MANY CHAU ENSURE CLARITY AND
CONSISTENCY WITH PREVIOUS.
ASSEMBLY REQUIREMENT EVEN
MINISTRATION AND CAR THAT ARE
GOING TO IMPACT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WILL NOT BENEFIT FROM THE
PROPOSED TAX CREDIT. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING DIRECTLY
TURNED ACTOR WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
PROPERTY. EIGHT BETTER OUTLINING
OUR- CONCERNS IT'S FORTHCOMING
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS STACY HERE A
MODEL ON BEHALF OF ROOM CO THE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION WE'RE
SUPPORTING EIGHTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN AND WE THANK THE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FORGETTING THE
MINISTRATION TO PUT IN THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
SUPPORTING AND EXTENDING THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE FIFTY SIX BUT THERE
ARE ANY OTHERS THAT INTENDED TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I
HAVE NOT DONE SO WE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS LILLIAN GLANTON A CONTRACT
PROGRAM RESOURCES- WE ARE AT THE
ON TECHNICAL SERVICE PROVIDERS
I'M TO THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY SURVEY. OF
CREAM CHEESE CALLED
IMPLEMENTATION PILOT PROJECTS
AND I JUST WANTED TO KNOW WHAT'S
FACING YOUR MODEM JUST IN HER
COMMENTS ABOUT THINKING. OF
SENATE- FOR PUTTING THROUGH THE
TECHNICAL LANGUAGE THAT TO
SUPPORT. YOUR VISION LAST FISCAL
YEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
MAKING THAT HAPPEN SO THAT
THIRTY FIVE. COMMUNITY SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT THE THAT THE
CAN BE NUMBER A SERVICE. WILL
NOT BE EXPERIENCING A GAP IN
SERVICES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT WEEK LINE THIRTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MICHAEL OVER
THE ASSOCIATION **** GROWERS
WHILE WE DO NOT IN A POSITION AB
EIGHTY FOUR WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
ADOPTING A TAX CREDIT EQUAL
AMOUNT TO COVER THE COST OF THE-
BUMPER OF OBVIOUS REASONS THAT
DON'T WORK IN THAT TWENTY TWENTY
TO. TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT WILL
WORK AGAIN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. NINE FORTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON BECAUSE CHER GONZALEZ
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY EIGHTY SEVEN IN
PARTICULAR THE PROVISION AND ONE
YEAR EARLY THE TEMPORARY LIMITS
ON THE ABILITY OF BUSINESSES TO
USE NET OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTION
AND RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT TAX
CREDIT. THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
SEVEN. THE MORNING CARE THE
MEMBER PRIVILEGED UP ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATE
IN SUPPORT OF JUST EIGHTY EIGHTY
SEVEN TO PHYSICALLY IN FOR THE
S. B. O. G. TACKLE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MANAGER COLONEL FOR
THE LINES INTO AT THIS TIME.
GREAT I APPRECIATE THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE TO CUT OFF A PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW BEFORE WE START ON
THE BILLS I JUST WANT TO CORRECT
AN ANNOUNCEMENT THAT IT BEEN
MADE EARLIER THE- BUDGET SUB
THREE COMMITTEE WILL START AT
ONE PM NOT ONE THIRTY AND IT IS
IN ROOM FORTY TWO A THREE. RIGHT
NOW WE- LET US- GO BACK. OUR THE
BUSINESS BEFORE US. AND WE HAD
WE- SORRY WE FIVE BILLS BEFORE
US SO I WANT T NOW PROCEED
WITH- OUR VOTING AND MOTIONS SO
WITH THE FIRST BILL IS AB ONE
FORTY SEVEN THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR AND WHO- SENATOR WHITE
COW SKI HAS MOVED THAT BILL AB
ONE FORTY SEVEN- ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY. QUESTIONS OR DEBATE
. I'M NOT SEEING NINE. THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS MISTER
STEP AND SHOW YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB ONE FORTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER. HI SKINNER AYE NIELSEN
. CABALLERO CAREER HIGH- DAISY I
RETIRE THE AYE DOLLY DOLLY NO
DORADO HI RADO HI EGGMAN RIGHT
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH KAMLAGER AYE
CAMARGO AYE LAYERED HI THERE HI
MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ MEN HI MAN I
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN HI THE
JUNGLE BOOK. TROUBLED NOT VOTING
PAN HI AN HIGH. STERN HI STERN
HI BY COUNTY HI MY COUNTY HI.
NIELSEN NO. ONE OF R SEVEN
THIRTY WE NEED TO HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE MISSING MEMBER OKAY
SO WILL HOLD THAT ROLE OPEN
RIGHT NOW THE VOTE IS TWELVE BY
TWO AND ONE NOT VOTING OKAY LET
US GO NOW TO- AB EIGHTY FOUR
THAT IS THE SUPPLEMENTAL PAID
SICK LEAVE MR LAYERED HAS MOVED
IT DO WE HAVE ANY- DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ALL RIGHT THEN MISTER
STEPPING JERRY CAN CALL THE ROLL
. AB EIGHTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS SKINNER HI SKINNER
HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO CABALLERO
HI COPYRIGHT HI. CORTESE CORTESE
HI DOLLY. ALI NO RAZA HI BROTHER
HI EGGMAN HI EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER HI LEHRER HI
THERE HI MCGUIRE MELENDEZ. MAN
MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI THE
TROUBLED. TO ABOUT NO PAN HI AN
HIGH STERN HI STERN HI MY COUNTY
BY COUNTY HI RIGHT WE WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN BUT THE VOTE CURRENTLY
IS TWELVE THREE. ALL RIGHT LET'S
GO TO AB EIGHTY SEVEN THAT'S THE
ECONOMIC RELIEF WE'VE GOT A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAN. AND-
SEEING NO- MIKE SEPT MISTER
SEVEN SHARP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB EIGHTY SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS SENATORS SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI
CABALLERO HI CABALLERO HI
CORTESE ALL RIGHT WHICH IS THE
HI DOLLY. DOLLY HI THE RAZA RAZA
HI EGGMAN HI EGGMAN I GROWTH
COMMAGER. KAMLAGER HI LAYERED HI
THERE HI MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ MAN
HI MAN I NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN HI
THE TROUBLED. GLOBAL HI PM HI
PAN HI STERN HI STERN HI MY
COUNTY HI MAKOWSKI HI RIGHT THAT
FOR NOW IS FIFTEEN THAT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN- WE WILL GO
TO AB ONE THIRTY NINE THE HUMAN
SERVICES CLEAN UP- MOTION BY
SENATOR PAD- PLEASE MISTER
STEPPING CHARCOAL THE ROLE. AB
ONE THIRTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS SKINNER. HI
SKINNER HI NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN
HI CABALLERO HI COPYRIGHT HI
CORTESE DIGI HI DOLLY HI DOLLY
HI DORADO. DORADO HI EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN I GROWTH CAMARGO. FROM HI
LAYERED. I MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ MAN. HI MAN HI NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE. SHOVEL HI
PAN IN FIVE STERN HI STERN HI
WHAT COUNTY MAKOWSKI HI. FOR A
THIRD THIRTY ALSO FIFTEEN AT THE
MOMENT WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
FINAL BILL WHICH IS AB ONE FORTY
TWO THE M. O. U. S. SENATOR PAN
OR SENATOR DURAZO SMOKE SO
MOVED- GO AHEAD MISTER STEPHENS
ARE YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL. AB
ONE FORTY TO THE MOTION TO PASS
SENATORS SKINNER HI SKINNER HI
NIELSEN. HI NIELSEN HI CABRIO I
CABALLERO HI CORTESE WHICH IS
THE I DOLLAR BY THE EARLY HI
RAZA I RAZA HI EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
I GROWTH CAMARGO. CAMARGO I
LAYERED LAYER I MCGUIRE WHAT HI
. MEN HI MAN HI NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NUMBER HI THE TROUBLE. JOE HI
PAN HI IN HIGH STERN HI MISTER
HI KIND OF HI I CAN HI. ALL
RIGHT THAT FOOD IS SIXTEEN EYES
SO AB ONE FORTY IS. BUT NOW WE
WILL THE MEMBERS ON THE OTHER
BILLS LET'S START WITH AB ONE
FORTY SEVEN ABSENT MEMBER. SORRY. ONE MOMENT WE WILL HAVE THAT
ROLL CALL. WE'LL SEE OKAY. GO
THROUGH CLASSROOMS. RIGHT WILL
NOW CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER ON AB. ONE FOUR SEVEN. AB ONE FORTY
SEVEN THE MOTION WAS TO PASS.
GROWTH MCGUIRE ACQUIRE I
MELENDEZ. ALL RIGHT I HAVE BEEN
UNDERSTANDING THE SENATOR
MELENDEZ WOULD NOT BE RETURNING
. ME JUST MAKE SURE IF WE HAVE A
NOTE ON THAT WE DON'T KNOW YET-
OKAY HAVE WE CONTACTED OUR
OFFICE. LET'S JUST GO THROUGH
THE FIRE ALL RIGHT TO LET ME
JUST CONTINUE TO GO THROUGH THE
APPS MEMBER I DO HAVE I WILL
CLOSE ROLE QUITE YET ALL RIGHT
AB EIGHTY FOUR. AB EIGHTY FOUR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS CENTERS
GROWTH. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
A. B- EIGHTY SEVEN. AB EIGHTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
SENATORS GROWTH MCGUIRE ACQUIRE
HI MELENDEZ. OKAY THAT'S GOOD AB
ONE THIRTY NINE. AB ONE THIRTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
CENTERS GROWTH MCGUIRE WIRE HI
MELENDEZ. RIGHT SIR- ERNEST
REQUIRED ALREADY VOTED ON AB ONE
FOUR TWO THANK QUE THANK YOU SO
I WILL WAIT JUST A COUPLE MORE
MINUTES. HIS. OKAY SO WE'VE JUST
LEARNED THAT ARE- THAT SENATOR
MELINDA IS NOT WILL NOT BE
RETURNING SO LET ME THEN- CLOSE
THE ROLE ON FIRST AB ONE FORTY
SEVEN TO VOTE WAS FIVE THIRTEEN
YES TO NARROW AND A COUPLE NOT
VOTING AB EIGHT FOUR THE VOTE
WAS THIRTEEN YES FOR NO. THREE
NO EXCUSE ME THREE NO- SO CLOSE
THE ROLE IN THAT AB EIGHTY SEVEN
THE FINAL VOTE WAS SIXTEEN I. AB
ONE THIRTY NINETY THREE CLOSE
THE ROLE IN AB EIGHTY SEVEN AB
ONE THIRTY NINE THE FINAL VOTE
WAS SIXTEEN HI SIR WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE ON THAT. END AB ONE
FOUR TO THE FINAL VOTE WAS
SIXTEEN HI SIR WE ARE CLOSING
THE ROLE ON AB ONE FOUR TWO. AND
WITH THAT. THAT CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS OF THE SENATE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE ON THE
EARLY ACTION ITEMS I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S ATTENDANCE THERE
SUPPORT THE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
STAFF WHO ASSISTED- IN THE-
FIXING OF OUR I. T. PROBLEMS SO
WITH THAT. WE STAND ADJOURNED.